that last one we did was [ __ ] up the
whole time
it was [ __ ] up the whole time well i
mean yeah it looks like it's [ __ ] up
this time too
like see it's it's like behind
okay it's going now on mine yeah okay
it's behind and it's real [ __ ]
glitched out yeah i know
it was doing that last time too and it's
like it never resolved itself
which is kind of going to drive me crazy
so i'm going to try not to like look at
myself
because i'm going to get really
distracted
good how is everybody oh [ __ ] it's
lagging like a [ __ ] that's what
i just said
the last one that we did was like lags
it lacks the whole thing
i think so yeah like the last movie
interview you guys seen a lot of lag
go ahead and comment in the comment
section it lagging pretty bad yeah
like i said it's gonna it's really gonna
bug me
the whole time so i'm gonna try not to
look at myself
all right i can look at the notes i
guess yeah
all right hey everybody
hey hey hey um we're gonna let some more
people show up we got some
like little announcements to make we got
some packages from people
yeah pookie's playing with the damn paw
which is one of the things that we got
today yeah
yeah so in case you guys didn't see the
card we're actually this the topic for
this show
was this wasn't even on the list this
was your idea because you had talked
about him
before yeah and you're like do we have
anything to
you know concrete plan to do like for
the next topic and i was like man not
really i was like i can change it he's
like let's do general butt naked
yeah this time it's time to get around
talking about the general
all right general he's a legendary man
um and it's very interesting story
and just wanted to talk about them you
know it this is kind of like a true
crime
story in a way kind of but it's also a
story about [ __ ]
war and war crimes and [ __ ] and just the
[ __ ]
bizarre ass [ __ ] liberian civil war
and the characters that came out of it
and yeah
and it's also i mean this is like a
crazy
story like i said it's messed up because
there's war atrocities
yeah but this guy is like he's
a monstrous person but also he's kind of
a fascinating person just because
of what happened later in his life yeah
he's funny as [ __ ] too
yeah and it's just like it's this
bizarre story and we even there's a
really good documentary um
that was funded by the sundance
foundation or sunday's channel or
whatever
and um it came out in 2011 and i think
it was called
the redemption of general butt naked we
watched it last night
and it was just like it was really
really interesting yeah it kind of went
less it went into the war atrocities a
little bit but it kind of more
went into like what happened afterward
you know
i'm not going to put i got to put it
into this poop
[Laughter]
she's like no i'm playing jared look
what's she doing right there there's
some treats right there she's tearing
into the damn
box oh okay the treats in it she's so
excited you guys
come here oh don't she's like i'm so
disappointed
that's actually one of the shout outs we
have like a lot of shout outs but just
like literally 15 minutes before we
started before we went live
um we got a box in the mail from a
from a fan named nancy she sent me this
really nice letter
um about uh how long she'd been
listening and we had been
you know cheering her up when she lived
overseas and stuff
and uh she's back in new jersey now she
also sent a big box of stuff for pookie
yeah a little sleeping bag and a little
treat ball and all kind of different
treats
and we have to say we did open a couple
of the bags and give pookie some of the
treats
and she really really likes yeah she's
trying to get back into them that's what
that's all about
that's why that's what all that noise is
she's trying to she's trying to tear the
bag
that's pretty rare she usually doesn't
like any treats besides those
temptations other than temptation that's
like kitty crack
because i've gotten her like a lot of
different kinds of treats we try
different stuff
out and uh like i got her some stuff at
aldi and
yeah she did she'll eat them but she's
not rolling throughs
right those ones she was just like
coming back for him poking the bag and
like
trying to climb back in the box trying
to get him and [ __ ] like that so this
must be really really good let's see how
many people we got now all right yeah
they're they're pretty much showing up
all right we can uh
what's the first thing we gotta gotta do
for the show well like i said
uh shout out so like i said thank you
very much nancy for all
for the big box that we just got that
was really really sweet of you i also
laughed because
she sent me another copy of this card
that has the kitty that looks like
pookie on it yeah because
she said well give the other one back to
tom because i got it for tom's birthday
card but then because i thought it was
so funny and it makes me laugh like
every time i look at it so she said to
give that
that one back to tom and then i can have
that one yeah so we can both have
something
which i thought was very funny that
looks just like that cat it really does
that looks exactly like her and she even
makes like little
little derpy faces like that which is
like what made me laugh about it
um i also wanted to give another shout
out to
louie for sending us the blue rays of
ghostbusters one and two like in one
pack and also all the predator movies
right it was the four predator movies
we're all in one uh pack so thank you
very much louie i think i
thanked him on one of the matches but
you know i like to do it on the main
show like i said
um also we have mailed out most of the
uh shirts for the 20 and over patrons
um and you know people that gave big
paypal donations and stuff like that
i think uh i just have i think four more
that i still
have to send because i had to order some
more blanks because i didn't have enough
of the sizes that i needed
um but they should all be out by the
middle of next week i would imagine
but we did like a huge mailing yesterday
we went to the post office
so um if you're a 20 over patron or have
given us a lot of
donations on paypal then look out for
those uh some of you got
you know was some of you got some of
these and we got like the new one that
we did
um and we're gonna send out some more
later on uh
so that's something to look out for
also um i'm not huge because you know
how i have uh
thank you very much matt thank you yeah
thanks matt
and uh yeah greg's in there plugging
unseen hand he said it was a great book
that is a great book
thank you very much oh thank you very
much yeah yeah if you guys haven't
if you guys haven't uh read unseen hand
or
or listen to the audio book uh you guys
should check that out because uh
that's a [ __ ] creepy ass book and she
compiled all the [ __ ] poltergeist
cases going back [ __ ] as
far back as she could how old do you
think the the first one was the first
one was from like
uh but like 500 ce
or something like that it was like you
know it's
the older ones didn't have as many
details obviously but
you know i tried to go back and find you
know the ones as old as i could find
because it seemed like there wasn't a
lot of books like that where they just
talked about poltergeist cases so i
thought that'd be a cool thing to do
yeah probably later on in the show
probably about halfway through
uh we'll take some orders for some
shirts too if you if you guys want a
[ __ ] shirt
you can um yeah show me them flashbulb
you guys don't have a shirt coming uh if
you uh do a uh
contribution of 20 bucks and send us
your address afterwards we'll verify
make sure you paid i'll ship you out a
snake pliskin shirt yeah because we need
because we need to do the size and stuff
like that yeah you can do your sizes in
your address because i
need to know like what blanks to get i
have like a bunch of blank extras but
you know i don't have every single size
yeah so but jiffy shirts is pretty quick
like sending the blank sizes
and like i said there were still like a
few people that were 20 not patrons that
still i think it's four people that i
still have to send the shirts out but
everybody else
yeah and and that's been and that's only
for continental united states for
england man
shipping alone is about between 15 and
20
depending on how it depended yeah it
depended on like how heavy the package
was because like some of the you know
some of the bigger shirts or
you know some of the heavier shirts
because the women's shirts are usually
lighter because they're
you know smaller and like but 20 u.s
continental i can i can pay the shipping
for 20. yeah yeah so uh but i think the
most expensive one was i think it was 27
to send one to australia which was
actually less than i was expecting
um for some reason i thought it'd be
more definitely real high shipping cost
yeah but i mean it's a long way so i'm
not really all that worried about it
thank you xanada thank you very much
enter the crustal sphere
thank you thank you thank you my man
also another thing i want to mention was
that some of you guys know it's like i
design board games and everything i've
designed a bunch of other ones but like
i said i haven't had the
money to buy a proof because you can't
put them on sale until you've actually
ordered a physical copy and like proofed
it
but i did order copies of some card
decks that i designed
uh i did this one which is like art
nouveau playing cards
kind of an absinthe sort of thing i have
a board game that's kind of like this
similar design too
uh got some ancient egypt ones there
and these are just uh standard card
decks but sometimes the suits are
different
and they kind of are designed to look
like you know various uh
things so to go with the theme that's
ancient greek playing cards there
and got some edgar allen poe
playing cards there that one has like
the the suits are like telltale hearts
like black cats
raven stuff um those will be on sale
shortly because these are the proof ones
which means i can put them on sale
and like i said i'm slowly ordering the
other games as well so i can eventually
put those on sale too
yeah and uh santa did you you can answer
in the uh comment section did you get
your booster yet
we've been talking about getting boosted
well he knows i'm talking about
cookies back there rolling that ball and
the treats are flying out of it but
she's not eating them
she wants to come out of the package
she's crazy
it's not the same she's like these are
different they came out of that round
ball
that's the same thing it's the same
thing poop yeah and now she's trying to
look that's gonna get underneath the
pillow
well cause like we had this old we had
an old similar one it looked like a
little like weeble kitty kind of
i don't even know what happened to them
yeah and it had treats she didn't like
it and it had
yeah and she used to like knock that and
it would come in that and the treat
would come out of the kitty's butt or
something yeah
i tried to trick her i put regular cat
food in it yeah we were out of treats
one time
yeah i would have put like meow mixer
after that she wouldn't chill and now
she does so she wouldn't want to i don't
even know where it went now she's
probably under the bed somewhere where
all of her other toys are
and uh another thing too and this might
be kind of uh awesome i gotcha
gotcha yeah okay oh bless you she's
amazing
because it's probably cause it's dusty
in here another thing too this might be
like uh a little bit in the future i
might do this starting around halloween
or maybe starting in the new year
i for some reason got i really wanted to
get back into horror fiction like
you know not just writing it even though
i'm going to finish my true crime stuff
but
um reading it as well because i'm kind
of getting behind on like a lot of the
new horror
so i'm i've decided that i'm going to
start like a new
either weekly or bi-weekly um like a
horror book
review show he's asking you a question
where
it's in the comments section uh where is
it where is it
wants to know where the where are those
oh it's going to be on the game crafter
yeah those
those yeah it's thegamecrafter.com i
haven't put them on sale yet but i'll
probably do it tomorrow
all right when they're on sale we'll
post a link somewhere yeah
i think they're i think they'll be like
8.99 or something like that i can't
remember
yeah i can't remember how much they they
are but um
you know okay yeah so like i said i got
a bunch of other games on there too that
are already uploaded but i haven't like
ordered a proof copy yet because some of
them are kind of expensive so i haven't
like
done that yet but eventually i'm gonna
have like a whole bunch of
games on there and i'm still working on
that halloween one that i hope to have
out by halloween too
but so like i said it's it'll either be
halloween or
not starting next year like in 2021 i'll
probably put it up on thursday same day
as the witching hour
it'll probably just be a short show with
just me like reviewing
a horror novel that i read mostly new
ones but i'll probably do old ones as
well
um i already have like a list of
probably like 30 35 books that i want to
cover
like on you know so that'll be something
to
if you're into horror books because i
know i had a couple people ask me to
recommend horror novels what's up neela
we sent you a shirt out bro
yeah we sent um actually we i have to
like
print his still and i think he's one of
the ones that i have oh that's the ones
we had
i have the blank yeah we just have to
print it tomorrow and then we have to
like
yeah there were somebodies i had to do
twice yeah because we messed up
the dye doesn't set in the shirt unless
you cook it
you need a high [ __ ] temperature
bloat you're gonna need to have a heat
gun heat gun
so if you shoot it the wrong way you go
[ __ ] that's not good enough
you can just put it in the water and the
dye come out and you can wash it again
and it's like it was never there it's
heat activated
yeah so a couple of them got kicked back
we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna mail them out uh when
well i have like i said i've got i have
one blank still to come
okay i got the couple packages yesterday
that had all the men's blanks in it but
i had one more woman's
shirt blank that i need to get so
there's like three or four people that
theirs didn't get mailed out yet yeah i
think it's four people but that's just
yeah yeah but um
pookie you stop it she's trying to dig
in the side of the damn box
no no don't do it she's being bad and
crazy
she is you should she was doing that
this morning too she like [ __ ]
i was trying to sleep in because it's
saturday which is like the only day i
get to sleep in
she's trying to dig through a cardboard
box yeah but of course cookie knock it
off
no she wanted us to get up so she was
just she wants to get in the box
i'm gonna get in the box let her get in
the box she can get in the box i'm not
gonna hurt anything she's gonna get hair
all over the t-shirts
that's all right
[Laughter]
okay you in there now no
she changed her mind she's a cat she's
like she's a cat she looked in there
went off
well now that it's open it's not funny
look at her
look at her trying to get dig through
the side of a damn box
hey stop it you're crazy she's great go
ahead
okay she's ridiculous
okay yes oh there bunya punter i just
sent your shirt yesterday
hey guys great to finally join in on a
live show yeah it's pretty fun
t-shirts with pookie's blessings yes
like i said some of them have been look
she's totally in the box now
licked by pokey oh man we're gonna get
that [ __ ] on [ __ ] camera
you guys got to see this
[Laughter]
okay it's kind of behind so oh my god
i don't know if i can see it oh yeah
okay now
hold on hold on what's this what's this
what's that i don't know what's it what
are you doing what's it let's cleavage
cam never mind where's that
that's good well it's behind it's
lagging it's lagging
look if she's in there what the [ __ ]
it's too dark can you see it she's in
there
i can't really see it but maybe other
people can see it i can't right there
yeah you're just gonna stay in there
folks
okay yeah all right that's uh
yeah now i'm trying to re-aim
everything this was a mistake it was a
mistake doing
that okay
that's that's all right i don't have to
be on camera
[Laughter]
that's about it that's close enough
close enough look at all this [ __ ] over
here
there we go
that's it all right that's better with
all that lag i was still able to do it
i'm a [ __ ] genius cat the kids come
back out all right
gotta get back to the show you say scoot
it over a little bit i feel like i'm
like way over here
what happened like i feel like
i feel like i'm way over the side and
the lag is driving me crazy i know
i wonder if it's like something i don't
know what the hell is the matter with it
just started doing that like the last
uh the last [ __ ] movie review that we
did
like on wednesday maybe that's gonna
leave the cleavage cam on
he was telling me yesterday you need to
start wearing it you need to start
wearing low-cut shirts again yeah we
were getting more [ __ ] we were
getting
a t-shirt channel's growing faster
channel was [ __ ] growing partially
from cleavage power
hold on we almost ready to do the show
yeah i think we're right 40 people hold
on one second
i got to get combat ready you got to get
combat ready just because because we're
going to be talking about a warlord
yeah african warlords and [ __ ] just in
case i start taking fire
okay here we go there we go all right
here we go [ __ ] bush cap
there you go come on hold on get that
[ __ ] cocked up
thank you oh my god thank you so much
all right thank you very much
yeah i'm glad the live shows are netting
you guys more moolah thank you very much
are there plans for a cooking segment
we've been like throwing that around
like thinking about that we are
going to do the cookbook yeah um
i don't know i always felt like we
should probably do that because
sometimes when you're in the kitchen
cooking it's like really funny
i wish i still had that i can't do it
live though
that's true there's too much prep work
and [ __ ] you know i mean i get
pissed because i get i get [ __ ]
sidetracked or distracted i'm like what
the [ __ ] was i doing oh [ __ ] didn't i
start
oh that would probably be the show there
well that's what i mean that's what
would be funny because sometimes i can
hear like if i'm in here working i can
hear him in the kitchen cooking
i'm an all in editing and i'll hear him
going i hate you i hate you
yeah yeah yeah i hate
talking to a tomato cutting it cut wrong
[Laughter]
yeah oh man i know it is very singing to
[ __ ]
yeah stuff and singing to stuff and
cussing at stuff
i do that too though well my mind my
mind starts getting into it you know
i start i do that to my computers right
when they're doing something that
is not yeah i hear something boom [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
why yeah that's wrong
it crashed i was right in the middle of
something yeah
yeah and it's just and it's when
something's being real because i'm like
the world's most impatient person
so if something like takes too long to
open i'm sitting there going come on
come on
come on come on i'm sitting there doing
that because this is why i do the same
thing when i drive which is why i don't
like to drive
i got that from my dad unfortunately but
yeah so
uh you want to start talking about
general butt naked yeah i'm getting i'm
getting fired up you're getting fired up
about talking about generals like naked
it's it's the it's the tequila well yeah
imagine something
that's starting to it's it's starting to
you know to yeah we're only 20 minutes
in the show i'm already so like look we
got these new glasses
if you guys aren't drinking this is
saturdays and we're [ __ ] you guys
you know i don't maybe it's maybe it's
early in the morning where you are in
the world i don't know but uh
on this show we drink we drink on this
show
we drink when we're not on the show
sometimes we drank a bunch last night
yeah
when we were watching well last night
because that's the excuse it's friday
night we don't drink every night we're
not alcoholics no
we usually just drink in the evenings i
don't i don't think i've ever drunk in
the daytime
well we have but not often
but yeah so so like i said last night we
were watching
um there's a really good documentary you
can rent it on youtube or we rented it
on xbox
it came out in 2011 and it's called the
redemption of general butt naked
and it's like a fascinating this dude is
like just so fascinating to me because
in a lot of ways i mean you could call
him a serial killer
sort of it's not really the same yeah
mass murder it's not like the same
motivation i guess
i'd call him i'd call him he's a tribal
warrior
yeah very much kind of a profile of any
other
tribal warrior throughout history almost
elements of spree killing
yeah well because that yeah him it is a
brigade the buck naked brigade
yeah now it was a situational stuff
though yeah
it wasn't just him it was a bunch of
other it's kind of like gang warfare
yeah there's a bunch of gangs trying to
take over the liberian government
in the name of their own tribes now
tribe may not have been
ethnic it might have just been area
neighborhood yeah
which i think was the case i think it
was more of the case of the liberian
liberian civil war but you know while
this was going on
other guys were torturing the president
to death on [ __ ]
live tv yeah samuel doe that yeah so
liberia was was no [ __ ] joke all
right
yeah you wouldn't want to go there for a
vacation not during those not during the
90s anyway
actually up until 2003 it was kind of
right
yeah and what was going on in liberia is
a good example of what possibly
can happen when emotion takes over a
society
and things can snowball and escalate
and insanity reigned for a long time in
liberia
they're still trying to hunt down all
the war criminals they really haven't
brought any of them to justice
or many of them to justice because they
know that to do so
would require would require [ __ ]
basically x and out a good deal of the
population so the war would just start
off again
because yeah because they have to round
up a lot of people
that's kind of yeah and that's kind of
when we were kind of having this
discussion while we were watching the
documentary because i said this is
giving me so many
conflicting emotions because there's
kind of
there's kind of a thing where because
we'll kind of get into it later but
you know general butt naked who i don't
know i'm sure this is probably
exaggerated but
when they asked him how many people he
would he killed him and his brigade
um he said it was probably no less than
twenty thousand
and even though some people have said
that that's probably an exaggeration
um he did actually kill a [ __ ] ton of
people innocent people
including women children um and
then he kind of like had a
you know christian conversion i guess he
became born again
and now he goes around being a preacher
like trying to
and trying to rescue like other kids
because it was mostly child soldiers and
everything
and trying to get them out of that and
he was one of the few
um you know warlords from this time
period that actually did go before the
tribunal and apologize
yeah he didn't run for what he did and
so in some ways like so i was like
really conflicted because in some ways i
could see
that like people who had been victimized
by this man or whose family members had
been killed by this man
you know i could understand if they
wanted to see him
um brought to justice they wanted to see
him executed they want to you know i
understand that
but then in some ways is it better
because that was what i was saying it's
like and i don't know if i could answer
this question because
i was trying to put myself in the shoes
of you know there was this one
particular woman whose
husband had been killed and whose
daughter had been uh blinded
um you know when she was a baby and she
lived when she grew up
and i was like if i if i was that woman
and this man
who had done this came to me and wanted
forgiveness
would i be able to give it or would i
would
you know would i rather like want to see
his head on a pipe
so you know what i mean so it's like a
really complicated
and i don't know if i really came to any
conclusion about it
but that's what kind of makes him so
fascinating and a lot of people too and
there's still like a controversy over
whether his conversion i'm not saying
that his conversion was [ __ ]
but some people have said that well he
undertook it just
for you know uh kind of like to save his
own ass because like well the warlords
you know they were bringing them all in
they were trying to bring them before a
tribunal they were trying to bring them
for the hague you know war crimes
uh commission and stuff and so he had to
reinvent himself to keep his ass from
getting killed but
in some ways he was one of the few that
actually came forward
yeah and admitted what he had done and
apologized for it and said you know i
don't want to be like that anymore yeah
that's the
um i guess you could say that's the
skeptical um
explanation of what had happened with uh
general bud naked my take on it's a
little bit different
um being being a veteran myself i think
we're gonna get into the details of the
story i think what ended up happening
is he had what jenny turned what jenny
she called it a moment of clarity
yeah and and that that kind of like that
kind of clicked with me i was like yeah
that's what it was it was a moment to
clear
he'd realized that he's like what the
[ __ ] am i doing
yeah he got caught up in it and it's
just too late
he had done so much evil you know
that there was no way to
get you know you know there was no way
to really rationalize or to justify
what he was doing and they were fighting
in a war that
ultimately really didn't mean a whole
lot it's not like you're fighting over
the imperial throne of rome
or anything you know what i mean where
you
taking control would save the entire
empire and millions of people
that's not what they were fighting for
it was basically petty
petty [ __ ] well and some of the armies
were really small some were wrong
100 people yeah so but he was uh they
called him butt naked because he didn't
wear any clothes in combat neither did
his commandos they were called the butt
naked commandos
and they did all kind of there was a
bunch of different kinds of generals
like general [ __ ] mosquito another
one
general mosquito spray and some some of
the armies dressed up as women
it was [ __ ] bizarre and in the case
of general butt naked he believed that
when he was naked he was bulletproof and
invisible
yeah and machete proof and machete proof
and
witnesses swear they couldn't see him
yeah
i don't understand it because they were
saying that he was coming at us naked
shooting and we couldn't see him yeah
well if you couldn't see him how would
you know he was naked right
this is this is juju magic and you know
when you're
in a country where everybody believes in
juju magic it
reality becomes distorted it's uh
they believe it so therefore it happened
yeah
you know it's an im it's it was an
emotional situation
yeah zanada says uh weren't drugs
heavily involved with these militants
they were yeah
um and he admitted that like i said a
lot of his uh commandos were
children or teenagers um that he would
give like put cocaine in their food
um and kind of get them all liquored up
like before
you know and then they would strip their
clothes off and go run around just child
sacrifice
involved too yeah african deities yeah
and um we'll get into it where do you
want to start jay
well let's kind of start well obviously
okay so like we're getting ahead of
ourselves yeah
i mean zach was saying it's like the
fact that that was somebody's name
that's not his actual name
no uh his name is actually joshua
bloggie
yeah um he's just better known as
general butt naked and like i said
during this liberian civil war
they had a lot of these kind of lower
level commandos
that you know took up these ridiculous
names there was one that was just called
chuck norris
yeah you know like i said there's one
called general mosquito general mosquito
spray
you know those two were like enemies
they were after each other it's like
yeah it's like it's ridiculous but it's
like
they were [ __ ] killing people they
were [ __ ] killed like with the
machetes chopping people's
heads off they were playing people yeah
they were [ __ ] doing
they were just shooting people's legs
off letting them live there was just
it wasn't a joke it was [ __ ] but it
was yeah
it was [ __ ] bizarre but it wasn't a
joke yeah they were [ __ ] for real
that's what it's like it's funny that
that's what his name was and that's what
he's known as
but it's like the [ __ ] that they were
doing was absolutely not funny yes
not it by not by any stretch of the
imagination no
yeah so he wasn't actually so general
but naked
was he was under the control of a
another liberian warlord
named roosevelt johnson now
at one stage uh
you know general butt naked was known
was known as the most evil man in the
world like i said because he claimed to
have killed at least 20 000 people
you know some people have said that's an
exaggeration um because he exaggerated
about other things like about his
history and stuff i think he meant he
was responsible for the dance
may have been because he did have it
wasn't just him he had like a bunch of
people
uh with him so he was actually he
started out um and this is his backstory
and like i said i'm gonna say right here
like all the articles that i've read
about him like vice talked about him
some there's been like a lot of other
articles about him and
you know the uh documentary that we
watched as well from sundance
they don't really they can't really
confirm a lot of the details about his
childhood or his upbringing so i'm not
sure how much of it
is myth making on his part so i'm just
like reporting this is
what he said like happened to him like
when he was a kid so
he said like he's uh originally from the
sarpo tribe in liberia
now he says that when he was 11 years
old
he was initiated as uh as a tribal
priest
when he was 11 and this was when he
underwent his first
human sacrifice now
he says that after this sacrifice there
was like this whole like three-day
ritual thing that they
went through and he says that at the end
of this he had a vision
um of essentially the devil although i
think it was one of the african deities
that he later associated with the devil
um and he said that the devil told him
that he would be a great warrior
but that to maintain his power he would
have to continue to
practice human sacrifice and cannibalism
in order to retain his magical powers
going forward
yep so yeah
so because he i guess he worked his way
up through the ranks
uh and he gets to be a high priest
and he eventually gets to be the
spiritual advisor
uh to samuel doe who was then the
president
of liberia now
this is kind of like okay so the god
that he was
um sacrificing to
was called nyan bay away
now he called this the amongst the first
three high-ranking gods in west africa's
black witch
coastal line division so i guess there's
like a whole
thing that there must be an african
pantheon set up
yeah which i'm kind of going off on a
little bit of a tangent here like not
really but um this kind of reminded me
of a case i was just writing about
uh in my faceless villain iv or faces
fill in millennium or whatever the [ __ ]
i'm gonna call it
that happened in london in 2001 they
found
a little boy's torso in the thames
like he didn't have arms or legs or a
head it was just a torso
and with orange shorts on and
during they they still haven't
identified the boy they just call him
adam
but um they found out
that this kid had been brought from west
africa
probably thank you very much bunyip
hunter
thank you very much i've been naked in
public before after one too many beers
and trust me everybody sees you it
doesn't work
damn damn that's a good one
that's a good one oh my god that's
delicious you tried it out
okay i don't think i've been pretty
drunk but i've never been so strong that
i was running around
i saw a video of general butt naked
doing a demonstration
okay a reenactment of a butt naked
attack
all right a one-man butt naked assault
he had clothes on
but he was running through the [ __ ]
demonstrating and he was doing it doing
the special moves
and the people were walking by and knew
who he was and they were running from
him like it was [ __ ] you know they were
they were
like [ __ ] that dude that's general butt
naked they were yeah because he was like
a legend
yeah it was like super scary and he was
running across the bridge and
[ __ ] doing imt individual movement
tactics you know what i'm talking about
and you know
pretending like he had his second m16
and uh
he said that being naked could allow you
to [ __ ]
move faster moving visibly and uh
your reaction time was a lot better and
what else did he say
he said you could you can power up your
abilities faster whatever that meant
yeah i don't think she could soak in all
the magical powers through your skin
yeah i think it might have been
something he might have been talking
about like when you saw a terminator one
how terminator would look at something
you see a schematic
yeah of what it was you were looking at
that might be
the special butt naked abilities that
happen faster maybe you you
analyze remember remember i told you
about ninja jim
yeah he swore them down that he had that
ability
we used to [ __ ] because when i see
something i see it from three dimensions
and this and that and
it says on a red background like
terminator yes it is terminator vision
because
yeah yeah yeah like that yeah that's
like we were goofing on him behind his
back [ __ ] ninja gym
come on ninja jam [ __ ] yeah i see
things in three dimensions i should have
sent ninja gem to africa
[ __ ] hang out with general butt naked
show him how to fight
it could be well because some of his uh
butt naked commandos would also wear
women's clothing like wedding dresses
and stuff or would wear like crazy
colored wigs
wigs and carry person stuff so i think
it was more like a psychological
tactic it was to terrorize people yeah
or like to shock people into being like
what the [ __ ]
stand there for a second right you see
it and you don't believe it
so you freeze and then it's exactly
that's that's kind of what i'm thinking
yeah so i don't think it was anything to
do with like
i don't know because like i said they
would go into battle
with they'd just be naked and they'd
have shoes on in the military
we called that that camouflage pattern
dazzle
yeah dazzle yeah dazzle [ __ ] came
from the navy back when they were they
were planning on taking [ __ ] like you
that you couldn't hide you no way you
can you hide a [ __ ] battleship
on the ocean with camouflage so [ __ ]
paint that [ __ ] and [ __ ] brightly
colored a confusing pattern so when you
see it you can't really identify it just
dazzles you look at that
[ __ ] yeah is that what size is that
which direction is it moving
that looks like the spaceship from
killer clowns from outer space yeah so
you're confused
slightly now go ahead are you saying so
i do kind of feel like that that's what
it is but no what i was saying was that
um
i kind of got off a little bit of a
sidetrack about this
uh this little kid's torso that they
found in the thames
and they discovered later on they still
haven't identified him they still don't
really know who killed him
but they think that the kid was
sacrificed to a west african like voodoo
god
a goddess rather called ocean and they
think that
that probably some rich west african
family
had imported this boy specifically
uh you know to sacrifice like for
power and you know wealth and luck and
stuff like that is this particular
goddess
so that just reminded me of that a
little bit because it's kind of the same
part of the world
um you know and some of the [ __ ] that he
was saying about
um you know he would take like little
kids
and he would like tie them to a pole
and then cut open their backs and pull
their hearts out through the back
and then like eat it yeah like for power
yeah and i mean he said that he actually
did that and apparently other people saw
him do that too so it's not he did
it yeah yeah like i said i don't know if
he actually killed 20
000 people but he did kill a bunch of
people
yeah he would sacrifice children before
battle yeah that was so they could have
victory in battle
yeah that wasn't really kind of you know
that wasn't just him though other ones
were doing that yeah
it was the same kind that's part of
[ __ ] african black magic it's juju
magic they did that kind of [ __ ]
yeah and it's not it's not alien to
african culture it's been around for a
long long time
so their their their culture and their
traditions are affecting their warrior
traditions also it's all part of the
same thing
yeah i mean they didn't like that though
you know what i mean africans didn't
approve of that
but it was it was around for a long time
yeah yeah
yeah in general it and like i said when
i was reading about the
the case of the the boy's torso that
they found in the thames
where even after they figured out that
it was like you know voodoo it was like
west african ritual magic
you know they said very very rare
i mean normally voodoo practitioners are
just normal it's just a normal religion
they don't like sacrifice humans or
anything this is like a weird offshoot
sect
because you know they don't they're not
uh down with that either
it's like the difference between
christianity and satanism yeah
they're part of the same religious
philosophy
yeah but it's like that's over this
right you know
most of us don't do that that's right
it's not right there can't be a satanism
without a christianity well yeah because
that's not the same as a christian
deity yeah or a christian figure right
it's the same thing in africa there's
black magic and white magic
yeah you know so that's all and uh ryan
did point out albino
uh africans are still sacrifices yeah
they are actually considered
children and you know by these
particular sects
um and albino uh albinos are
usually seen as very valuable yeah um
yeah somebody said well wouldn't like if
you were running around on the street in
battle like wouldn't your [ __ ] dick
flop around and stuff
yeah it did they got pictures of him
he's sitting there [ __ ] butt ass
naked with a [ __ ] m16
and a lce with carrying his ammo and
he had a necklace on and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] jump [ __ ] swinging
he didn't care it just seemed like it
would be really uncomfortable i mean
like that would be like
me no running around without a bra dudes
were fighting naked for [ __ ] tens of
thousands of years
it would just be like nah dudes were
fighting [ __ ] naked
[Laughter]
you know i don't like no there's you
know wearing a kilt they don't you know
[ __ ] you know you know there's no
underwear underneath the kill same thing
well i mean technically you're not
supposed to wear underwear under a kilt
i think in ancient times they didn't no
they probably didn't you know what i
mean
wow what the hell did people do you know
you just got used to it
and is everything like [ __ ] flapping
around
africa is hot too you know what i mean
so
didn't bother tammy says it's all i can
imagine is this guy running around with
his winky bouncing around like tom hardy
and bronson right
yeah exactly exactly well there like i
said
there's the photographs of it yeah going
full
[ __ ] general butt naked uh you know
that's crazy with this m16 and
everything in public
yeah people took pictures of them like
that well they're right
there is a picture i haven't seen it but
apparently there's a very famous picture
of him when he was younger
and he's you know naked in the back of a
pickup truck
and he's got like his his gun in one
hand and apparently some
other man's genitals that he cut off the
other hand and the other hand
yeah so that's pretty special in the
photo that they did show where he was
just in the middle of the street
everybody's [ __ ] runner from him
he looked crazy as [ __ ] man eyes the
size of saucers
yeah teeth ground like i said they were
all drunk and like on drugs and [ __ ]
yeah which i'm sure didn't help so yeah
because you know you get real drunk you
run around yeah and african fighters
don't [ __ ] like take cover or
anything they were just standing out in
the middle of the street [ __ ] jumping
out yeah they weren't worried about like
getting behind the wall or kind of like
dueling cut out in the middle of the
street
yeah you know i guess that was kind of
considered can be considered like
cowardice you know what i mean so
they're out there dueling you know
basically essentially
standing up there trading shots at each
other yeah yeah
so uh so at this point uh joshua let's
call him that because i don't want to
say general butt naked every time his
real name's joshua
yeah but uh so
what's funny is they were talking i was
creating mad [ __ ] about him he's
he's he's he's friendly now
you know when you see him i feel the
weird thing about it it's like i can't
god i was just i was very normal i was
so conflicted
like watching the [ __ ] because i can see
i can totally see
why um why people would just
would forgive him i mean he seems like a
teddy bear
now it was the stress of warfare
that's what it was but then i don't want
to but then on the other hand i don't
want to be one of those people that
should be like oh he's so nice now it's
like but and then like forget like all
the horrible [ __ ] that he did
so i don't know like i said i'm just
it's very i'm very no one is 100
good you know what i mean yeah but it's
like i haven't sacrificed any children
with machetes so it was it was all on a
continuum it was situational it had
i think yeah i think this it built up
it built up there was a synergy of the
warfare you know i mean hatred and
violence and anger on all sides are
building up and he's an alpha male
personality
okay he's got good genetics and good
genes
for natural leadership and warfare he's
bigger than the rest of the guys
he was he's intelligent he's not dumb
he's intelligent and he's
more intelligent than the guys that he
was coming up around
so they look to him for leadership and
they look to him for success
in battle to try to get their side to
win
which of course puts a lot of
responsibility on him
he's fighting guys that are pretty
savage so you got to out savage them
yeah and that's where all that [ __ ] came
from
and he started to get to a point where
he's i think like you said he had a
moment of clarity he's like
[ __ ] you know i'm becoming a monster
yeah you know and not becoming he was a
monster
yeah even monster now and and he's like
uh
and we're not really fighting over
anything
because i think they're not kind of
occur to him that it's like what the
[ __ ] are
what what is all this for yeah i think
that's what happened
i mean he didn't say that outright but i
think that's kind of what he couldn't
say that because
the butt naked commandos were still
around and he still cared about him
and he was the one that forced them to
fight and gotten and made them into
commandos over time
so he's not going to come out to them
and go you know what that [ __ ] that we
did
we did all that for nothing yeah yeah i
mean because they had sacrificed and
lost a lot
and you know they kind of got bonded
together through [ __ ] warfare
so he can't let them down that way yeah
he just has to say it's peace time now
we gotta you know
and we got and he wanted to answer for
his crimes he did
he does i will give him that he did want
to answer for it but um
and he was the only one they didn't go
after because he showed up
yeah he was one of the few that they
suggested amnesty because
he he he does he he seemed like
yeah he's genuinely sorry he knows that
there's no way he can reverse all that
[ __ ] that he did
he's just going to try to do the best he
can yeah
and try to improve the situation you
know apologize to everybody
like i said it's like and you know and
uh bunyam hunter brought up a good point
he said how many people do you have to
kill before forgiveness becomes
impossible
that's kind of what i was thinking when
i was watching that because i was
thinking
in some ways because we do a lot we talk
a lot about serial killers on this show
and it's like obviously
those dudes have no [ __ ] excuse
because they did not
you know grow up they didn't grow up in
the same situation yeah and they're not
at war
and it's not like a wartime so this is
like different i'm not saying that
like i said i'm not excusing it but it
the situation is different
and the fact that
and like i said there was this one scene
at the end that was really bothering me
where
he goes back to you know this woman
whose husband he killed
you know many years before and his baby
he had blinded and she was like you know
grown up or she was a teenager she lost
one eye she yeah she lost one of her
eyes yeah
and um so he's like there in front
and he's just like you know you have to
forgive me you have to you know i'm i'm
really sorry and everything
and i was trying to i you know i was
putting myself in her shoes
and i i genuinely could not decide
what i would have done in her situation
i mean she eventually i mean
obviously when he first came there she
looked like really
she's like oh [ __ ] this i don't want
anything to do with and the same with
the kid
but after he had like talked to them and
he seemed genuinely
um you know he seemed to genuinely sorry
he seemed genuinely apologetic
and so you know both of them went to
you know one of his revival things or
his church sermons or whatever and
you know but in a way that kind of made
me uncomfortable too because it seemed
like he was using them
to be like oh you know see i killed this
woman's husband and
[ __ ] up this girl and they forgave me
so it's i don't know it's like it just
seems like
i want to like because he seems i know
this is a weird thing to say but he
seems like such a nice
man even though he did all these
horrible things
but then some some things that he does
seem
kind of self-serving in the way that
he wants everyone to forgive him and
then and the narrative of because
you see this a lot particularly in
evangelical circles
um i think they're really into
the idea of like i was like one of the
world's worst sinners
which this guy obviously would have been
if you kind of look at it through that
framework like i killed 20
000 people or whatever um and now i've
you know now i've found jesus and i'm
like trying to redeem myself and i'm
going around apologizing which is good
but it can seem a little cynical also
because i don't know it's just there's
something about it that kind of bothers
me so you're also not dealing with the
same culture
trail okay this is a culture that where
religion
and magic are blurred all right it's one
that's the same
thing for them and he's a guy you're not
talking about an albert einstein type
guy you're not talking about a guy with
a formal education or anything
he was not educated he's of good
intelligence all right
i'd say he's probably about 130 iq
probably
um he's very shrewd yeah but he's
carrying a heavy load of guilt
yeah i know he is he did come across
like he did genuinely feel bad
so yeah it is self-serving he he wants
to be forgiven
because he regrets it and he wants the
load taken off of him
all right yeah but he does know that you
know what i mean
that he killed all these people and pry
for no he does seem very self-aware yeah
he knows you know
because he did say because at one point
he kind of said he goes to this one guy
whose legs he had shot off like the guy
had no legs and he was like in a
wheelchair
and he said something that kind of
bothered me at first he said you have to
forgive me and i said to him i was like
no he doesn't really have to no you
don't have to forgive somebody that did
that to you i probably wouldn't
but i think i think that was also you're
reading too much into the language their
english isn't isn't that good
if you notice that there's a lot of the
their terminology is it was not real
precise
uh you're not dealing with formally
educated people who are really precise
in the way they word things
you have to forgive me i think might
just mean
please forgive me yeah maybe he didn't
mean it like
the way that he worded it like that was
kind of unfortunate i think it just
meant i think it just made it because i
was like no one has to forgive you right
you know what i mean i think you're
you're reading too much into the wording
he just he just meant please forgive me
what he meant
graham townsend said would you forgive
stalin or hitler i had thought the same
thing like when i was watching that
if if hitler had come out you know
instead of like blowing his brains out
you could write no
but if he had come out later on and said
that he was actually sorry for doing
that it's like i don't think anyone
would have forgotten
no no a very dif very different
situation because
stalin and hitler were conducting what's
called institutional or highly organized
that's true they did actually kind of
more i feel like in this situation like
i said i'm not saying it's good i'm not
i think it's better those people are
still dead
but i don't think as much they didn't
put as much
thought into it yeah i mean hitler and
stalin put
thought in right and also they weren't
in any personal immediate danger
trail from any of these people that they
were killing uh but naked was in danger
he was
at the front of the battle you know he
was being shot at along with everybody
else
so he'd lash out and kill anybody he
thought was an enemy
at any moment you know but he could be
killed also
you're dealing with ptsd type behavior
also
you're not dealing with a person who's
thinking things out rationally
this is all impulse immediate impulse
and and and emotion so you're not
talking about somebody who's clearly
thought this through yeah that they have
i mean the thing about hitler and stalin
is that they had
institutions in place for doing that
specific thing yeah
yeah particularly hitler who had all
these [ __ ] camps built and [ __ ] like
that and this is what we're gonna do
i would say i would say also stalin
stalin was even more cold-blooded yeah
i mean being an enemy of the nazis was
gonna put you in the grave
being a friend of the commies would put
you in there in your grave they killed
enemy and friend alike
cold blood cold yeah well that's that's
the scary thing about
authoritarian right things like that is
that you never know when they're gonna
you know you might be in their good
graces now but it's like tomorrow
you might they might decide they don't
like you at least at least with
the the the german national socialist
party or the nazis at least you knew who
their enemies were
they clearly told you who their enemies
were
not not the con not the communists the
communists would kill a good commander
if you were too good of a communist
they'd kill you
they go he's a he's a threat to my
[ __ ] promotions you know this guy's a
threat
and uh or they also some some guys in
the
in the communist regime were kind of
forced into the communist regime and
hated it
but they had to play along and they took
their frustrations out on good
communists they're like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm gonna send
him to gulag yeah
yeah i mean it didn't secretly well
everything it was it was all very
backstabbing yeah backstabbing [ __ ] um
yeah maria asked it's like did he offer
to provide concrete economic and social
support for the blinded girl
what do you think that [ __ ] had no
money well what he did end up doing and
what happened later on yeah because like
i said evangelicals
evangel well that's not good well no she
wasn't blind dude but she's right
evangelical christians in the u.s um
have actually been sending him
money because like i said they love a
redemption story
yeah and the worst that you are to start
with and
you know because it took you so much
more to get to that point it's like look
how evil this person was
and they were redeemed and jesus loves
them and blah blah
so this is a good selling story so they
love that kind of [ __ ] yeah that that
narrative they love yeah
so there are actually some evangelical
christian groups in the us
um or you know it's not like a whole
group but it was like a few
couples and they do actually send him
money
now i don't know if this is true or not
because he did
uh for a time he did like open a center
he has like a house
where he houses um a lot of the
uh you know ex-child soldiers that he
forced into service because a lot of
them were forced into service
um or because they didn't have any other
opportunities and they didn't have
anything else
yeah they were orphans or whatever so he
does he did like have a house for them
to stay in
um he actually did try to convert them
and he has like all these rules like you
can't drink you can't smoke you can't do
this that you can't fight you can't do
this and that the other
and it does seem like he was trying to
improve their lives in some ways like he
got them driver's licenses he tried to
like the un came into and we're trying
to like you know give them job training
and various other things um i'm not sure
like overall how success because he
there's allegations that he took some of
the money
for himself and didn't use all of it for
what its intended purpose was
i don't know how true that i like i said
i've read some articles that said that
he didn't use all the money for them but
he did use some of it for them like
buying them food
yeah yeah he's not a rich guy he's
basically
a traveling preacher begging for money
really
and i think he gets most of his money
over for like he said from christians
overseas
yeah but i don't think i think he has a
house with some
he has a wife and some kids yeah but
he's not with them most of the time and
i think right now
i think he's on the border he's just
across the border in ghana
he did go to ghana because yeah there
were some
as the regime started to change out they
were they started to kind of like hunt
down
what they consider what they call war
criminals yeah from that era
but that government you know i mean who
they're going to consider a war criminal
is probably somebody who was
on the opposite side of them you know
they're not going to [ __ ] go after
their own war criminals the other war
criminals
uh you know it's difficult to know
what's true coming out of a
it's like it was kind of weird because
it seemed like they
suggested i mean the the thing about the
tribunal was that
they had a tribunal you know they you
know showed it on tv it was live on the
radio it was like a big like
everybody watched it like in liberia but
the tribunal
essentially didn't really have any power
they were just like making suggestions
like we think this person should be
convicted or we should think this person
should
um you know face justice at the hague or
whatever for war crimes
but they didn't really have any power to
back it up like they couldn't actually
do anything about it yeah
so they did actually suggest amnesty for
general but naked but
a lot of the other war criminals they
didn't but the weird thing too was that
some of the people that they didn't
suggest amnesty for hadn't actually
killed anyone directly but it just
funded you know some of the warlords
that had killed people
like there was one um i think there was
one woman
and she became like some kind of high up
in the government like later and she had
given like ten thousand dollars to one
of the warlords at some point in the
past
and she was on the war criminals list
too even though she hadn't directly
killed anyone
so they thought it was very weird that
you know general butt naked wasn't on
the war criminals
you know or was suggested amnesty but
she wasn't it's gonna be african
politics right and all that
you know what i mean but like i said it
was kind of a moot point because they
that tribunal didn't really have any
power
to do anything they can't go after any
of those guys because it would tear the
[ __ ] liberia apart they just go back
to fighting
well and that's why some people in the
country because they interviewed kind of
a lot of people
um on both sides of the issue like do we
think that we should give him amnesty do
we think he should be prosecuted and
some people were like yes we wanted to
see him prosecuted because of all the
[ __ ] that he did
but some people said you know it it
wouldn't serve anyone anything because
it's like he seems like he's sorry now
he doesn't look like he's gonna do
anything else
and if we started prosecuting all these
people would it just kick up all these
civil wars again which nobody wants
it would so yeah so i can kind of see
both things so
so it seems like almost kind of like he
got away with murder
but then in some ways if you did go
after him would it just make it worse
down the line
he got away with murder but so did all
the other ones right and you know he was
only one of them there was a bunch of
other ones that
no one's heard a peep out of and they
haven't come forward or
fessed up to what they did or helped
anybody they just they're just
laying low yeah
i think he's the least of their troubles
you know he's just not
yeah i mean i don't really see him going
back
to that yeah um you know unless
everything just descended into chaos
once again in which case he probably
wouldn't be the only one that did it
he would have i think he would probably
go to ghana he'd run i mean
yeah because that's what he didn't want
later yeah
um so that was kind of another thing you
know that he did actually go to ghana
and like a lot of the
you know child soldiers who had then
grown up at that point and they he was
kind of giving them a place to live and
a kind of a purpose like
finding them jobs and things and um they
were kind of upset
that he had taken off and left and his
wife and kids were also kind of upset
that he had taken off and left because
she was just kind of like yeah i don't
really want to do this by myself so i
don't know where the [ __ ] he went
um so she was kind of mad but i think
they're still married as far as i could
tell
um so it does seem like if [ __ ] went
down again he would probably just take
off
which i guess is the best possible
solution it's just like it's so
it's such a complicated issue
that i don't i just really don't know if
there's a good solution
for anything because i like to think i
don't know
it's again i'm kind of going back to
trying to put myself in this one
particular woman's position
where if somebody who had done something
horrible to me
um you know came and was actually like
with actual contrition
it was actually like apologizing for it
i don't know if i would buy it and i
don't know if i would accept it
i probably wouldn't because i'm kind of
spiteful like that
but and i and i'm always kind of like if
you were an adult
it's one thing if you were like you know
super [ __ ] up on drugs or you were
drunk or you were a kid or something
like that
i'll give you more leeway in that
situation but if you were grown up and
if you're
in your right mind and you still did
that [ __ ] up [ __ ] it's like it doesn't
do me any good to like apologize for it
now because you
should have thought of that before you
[ __ ] did it in the first place you
know what i mean
i'm kind of more that kind of person so
i don't know if i would have accepted it
or not
but i can see how yeah the liberian
civil war was not a normal situation
it's yeah that's true it was the
collapse of [ __ ]
a collapse of a civilization that was
all ready to corrupt to begin with
and it was just like a bunch of warlords
struggling for power
and if you were in that game you know i
mean and he got into that game next
thing you knew it turned him into a damn
monster
yeah and like you said he wasn't the
only like i said not excuse me
but he wasn't the only one that did all
that kind of [ __ ] and a lot and it was
you're in a kind of do or die type
situation
if you're not 100 vicious and fighting
like crazy
you could fall into the hands of the
enemy originally if they won and what
they would do to you was a fate worse
than death
i mean the damn tortured the president
to death on live television
they did yeah what i mean so if you were
general butt naked you were also
fighting for your life
well yeah and i and i feel like after
samuel doe got
executed by the other side because uh
general butt naked was on the same side
as doe
yeah so after that happened what they
would exactly
what made him yeah get the [ __ ] out and
go to ghana because he's like oh well
i'm next on the chopping this is
this is conan level [ __ ] warfare it
is it just happens to have m16s and
it's sad because there's like you know
there's tons of people there and you
could see it like
when they did the tribunal and he came
forward and said and they asked him how
many people he had killed and what he
did
and he said 20 000 people every single
person in the room just
gasped yeah aloud like they couldn't
believe it
um but they did kind of they were happy
that he had turned up
because i believe he was the only one
that did yeah uh that was accused
when he said 20 000 people on the street
started laughing because he didn't kill
that many
yeah most people like he's bragging and
i've read a lot of
which is [ __ ] up i mean that's not
something to brag about but you know
what i mean it's
it's kind of like um you know i've read
a lot
a lot of stuff even journalists that
have been over there like you know uh
sociologists stuff that have lived over
there like since the 70s or whatever
and they're like look this you know
we're not saying what he did was good
but it's like he probably didn't kill 20
000 people it's myth-making
yeah and he's very aware that that's
what he's doing they're like
all the [ __ ] about um him being like uh
you know doing the the tribal [ __ ] when
he was 11 and like you know
getting to the top by like engaging in
like these tribal combat and all this
other kind of stuff they're like that is
probably [ __ ] like most of it
they're like it's probably just
exaggerated
give yourself a good traditional story
yeah he's trying to just give himself
like an exciting
narrative yeah because he knows that one
i mean once that time period had passed
like all the liberian civil wars had
passed um they're like a lot of the
warlords had to quote unquote reinvent
themselves and they're like that's
essentially what he's doing is he's
making himself
this kind of mythical figure yeah um
like almost like a folk hero right
kind of trying to he's trying to he's
trying to emblazon himself
in the into the damn culture and
heritage
the cultural heritage of liberia yeah to
make himself like you said a folk hero
you know yeah jeremiah johnson style
[ __ ]
yeah and and i think that he's very
aware that that's what he's doing
um he seems to be very aware that that's
what he's doing he's like so some of it
is i'm not saying that he's not
genuinely sorry for what he did
he does seem to be but he's also very
i mean he's written like five books too
that he's trying to sell
and like i said he's been on like tons
of different what's a hell of a story
man
it is we haven't even told his war
stories not really he has some [ __ ]
badass horror stories
yeah it's like some [ __ ] straight out of
conan
yeah yeah so like i said whether this is
[ __ ] or i don't really know but
he said how he got to the top of the
heap like you know in the you know
priesthood or whatever
was through combat like the african
version of the kumite
i guess so that's how yes that's how he
gets to the top because that's how they
picked
who got to be like the high priest man
we're going to have to whoever was the
biggest person that could like beat the
[ __ ]
i would love to see steven segal go down
there to go [ __ ] hang out with
general butt naked and see
how if butt naked calls [ __ ] on
[ __ ] steven seagal
i would pay to see that actually yeah
would be very funny maybe
steven would be and you know it's weird
because speaking of kumite
that was another thing that general butt
naked would do
with his child soldiers not only would
he give them cocaine and booze
but he would also show them jean-claude
van damme movies yeah yeah because you
have to
the kids that he had fighting some of
them were as young as nine
you guys and um he liked childs a lot of
them liked child soldiers because you
know they were very valuable
and um you know because you could kind
of and they weren't afraid of
dying they're not afraid of death so
then so he would show him all these like
american action movies
so and he said this specifically he said
because so you could see
he's like i would show them one action
movie and all these people got killed
and then i would show them
another one with the same actor in it to
show them that he was alive again
so it would almost seem like it wasn't
real
no he was trying to he was trying to let
he was trying to teach them that you
came back
in the next movie yeah like a
reincarnation yeah he was showing him
that look
um dolph lundgren died in this movie but
in the next movie he's
alive against and you're the same way if
you die you'll come back so he was
trying to take their fear of death away
essentially
and well little kids [ __ ] think
they're invincible anyway they do
and they you they love to uh to have
some kind of job
yeah and you give them a gun they just
[ __ ] love it yeah yeah you can see
that yeah
they just looked like they were having
the [ __ ] they [ __ ] love it there's
this weird oh they
forced those young boys to go to become
child soldiers
there's a whole process and it's well
[ __ ] documented well some of them
were
worried about some of them did join
there's a couple different ways that
they
do it all right i've studied how they do
it and there's a couple different ways
some of the most brutal ways is to make
them kill their own parents
yeah and you they break into their house
you know the army moves into the village
they get into the house and they tell
the kids
[ __ ] you kill your parents or i kill
you
well they kill their parents and then
afterwards they tell them
they say you're in the army now and then
they [ __ ] take them away from the
village and they said
you killed your own parents because
you're weak
a strong boy would have [ __ ] chosen
death
yeah okay but because you're weak you
killed your own parents and we're gonna
make you strong
all right so you can face death you know
what i mean like a hero
and that's how they [ __ ] do it and he
says the kid that killed their own
parents
that was a coward and he's gone now
we're gonna make we're gonna make
you into a new person all right one that
can face death
you know with bravery so it's a lot more
sophisticated than you think it works
yeah because you're dealing with a child
yeah okay
like i said you can if you get them
young enough yeah
and then a few years later it's like
that didn't even happen to them that
that was another kid
you can call it brainwashing you've
erased the you've erased the other
because they're ashamed of what they did
so they have to erase that personality
with a new one yeah all right which is
easier than it
sounds yeah cia's been doing mind
control for a long time back to the 60s
you know there were
we we talked about that earlier on the
show and what they were doing up in
canada
yeah you know and it's been rumored i
don't want to get into it but there's
rumored
but they were doing to [ __ ] force
multiple personalities into [ __ ]
girls
through sexual abuse to turn them into
assassins that was another one thing
that they
yeah that it was the nazis had found
that out
i mean the thing is i think that the
reason i don't know if you could i mean
obviously there's been programs to do
this kind of thing i don't know
if it's not foolproof enough
i don't think because it it depends on
the person like i don't think every
single person
would react the same way to the same
stimuli like i don't really think
because um you know multiple personality
disorder
is very very very very very rare
um and usually you only see it with
you know horrible horrible horrible
abuse
so you would really have to do something
and even
with horrible abuse because you see like
hundreds thousands
of cases of people that went through
horrible abuse as children
and didn't develop multiple personality
disorder because like i said it's very
unusual
so i think there's only like a specific
very specific like personality type that
would do that
so it does seem like i can see why they
would look into trying to
do that to somebody on purpose as
[ __ ] [ __ ] up as that is
yeah but i don't know if it's foolproof
enough to
make someone like a manchurian candidate
type of
friend evidently they didn't care what
they did is they would do it to a bunch
of them
and the ones that failed they killed
they only kept the ones that lived well
the ones that did it you see yeah it's
just like
early on people are always saying like
like on another show i said
you know that torture was effective and
people go oh that's not true torture was
ineffective
they proved that it was ineffective now
you have to understand the context of
the torture
torture is highly effective but it's
only effective if you can kill the
person
all right america couldn't couldn't
torture because
it was against their laws all right it's
not effective they'll tell you anything
all right and then they have to
so they couldn't use real torture saddam
tortured people
and it was effective because the purpose
of the torture was not
to get information out of the person the
purpose of the torture
was to terrorize the population that's
what its true purpose was
which if that's your purpose that's the
problem yes it should be torture does
success torture
it doesn't succeed in getting useful
information uh
it can it can but i don't think you have
to verify it
it's the kind of situation where you
you say look i know that you know this
even though you lying you don't know the
person knows this all right you will
tell me or i'll kill your child
because i don't know it you kill the
child and then guys guys
i didn't know i don't know what i can't
tell you and then you kill him
then you move on to the next [ __ ] uh
you move on to the next suspect
because the dudes that do this don't
care yeah that they killed the child
and that they killed the man they got
more people they can kill they don't
give a [ __ ]
these are all excess people they're just
looking for the information
yeah they'll kill 20 000 of them to get
the [ __ ] information they don't care
right so in the context of america yeah
torture doesn't work but in the context
of saddam hussein yeah it worked
because it killed they were able to kill
20 000 people and it terrorized the
population
and they got what they wanted eventually
yeah so
it all depends on the context yeah like
i said it all depends on what's right
yeah right but the main purpose of
torture is to
terrorize the population you want the
population to know
if i fall into the hands of the secret
police i'm dead
so i better [ __ ] be good it's like
preventative maintenance
you know what i mean yeah and that's how
iraq was held together fear that damn
secret police in abu ghraib prison
the fear of it helped it keep it
together
yeah yeah now and uh and the torturers
that did all that [ __ ] in abu ghraib
guess where they got him they got him
out of prison
they would find a person who was a
sexual sadist and go would you like to
work with us we'll let you out of prison
and they would make that person
a secret policeman yeah and turn him
into a torturer
yeah so you didn't have to [ __ ] train
a torturer you got them out of prison
you recruited them
yeah they'd look and go oh you're a
sexual sadist you raped this many people
you killed
boy we'd like to work with you imagine
the u.s government you don't seem like
the type of people
type of person yeah how would you like
to leave prison and make a hundred
thousand dollars a year
and do what you do for us oh yeah sure
and that's that's where they got them
from
well yeah because you're like well can
you imagine like going to some [ __ ]
serial killer or something like that
and being like hey we'll pay you and
give you a chance to prison for it yeah
and give you a ban
and just work with impunity they just
were like yeah sign me up
yeah exactly because some people are
terrible yeah
thank you very much dj d d l j yeah
thank you 78
well a lot of guys running the damn
concentration camps you know
capos and [ __ ] like that were taken out
of prison yeah
you know and uh the guys that ran
certain aspects of [ __ ] the of the of
of the the nazi german concentration
camps
were specifically selected because they
knew they were sociopaths and
psychopaths
they knew yeah i could see how that
would be really helpful having those
personalities and they're like we're
going to put you in charge of this camp
in this camp and they are they had plans
to kill them
once all the [ __ ] inmates were dead
well yeah cause like
because you can't trust that
[ __ ] well yeah of course not
so that's what i'm saying about
institutional evil there's a big
difference in the you know the nazis
were gonna [ __ ] over their own people
because they knew that [ __ ] was
a nut yeah you know i can't let him let
him live
after he killed all those people but
anyway
we got to get back to the yeah uh ryan
said did butt naked run that country for
a while he didn't really know
he didn't really run it he was just like
um a small time warlord
he worked for like one of the bigger uh
you know samuel doe who was the
president for
a while but then he got executed by like
the other tribe like took over and
there's a bunch of factions fighting for
power over liberia
yeah and like i said in one of them this
is just like we're talking about like
the small tribal armies like i said it's
only like 100 dudes or
but naked commando i think was i think
about naked commandos was a few dozen
guys
yeah it was a very very small these were
just very small groups fighting each
other
there's a lot of um uh footage of
some of the battles because there were
like journalists and stuff there so you
can see there's just
you know there's just a couple dozen
dudes like run around the street
like shooting at each other yeah that's
absolutely that was a whole battle you
know we
liberia was a is a poor country
and mostly disarmed so
12 guys with m16s and ak-47s are
bringing a lot of power
to bear you can you can work with that
in that environment
you couldn't work with that here in the
united states man [ __ ] everybody's
got an ak-47 or m16 those things are
everywhere here
so 20 guys like that you wouldn't even
put a dent in you
in terms of the [ __ ] power dynamic
here not enough
somebody asked are we all naked in honor
of the topic of the show
i see what you're doing i see what
you're doing you're trying to get us
clearly we're not but if you guys
[Laughter]
yeah so ryan says so just a [ __ ] show
with a small militia
yeah yeah pretty much it's just like
little little militias like all fighting
each other
it was two main factions
but you have like i said you had the
president samuel doe and then you had
the other guy whose name was prince
something prince johnson or something
like that and so the two of them were
like rivals
so you had like his dudes and the other
dudes dudes and they but
they were like a lot of infighting in
between it was just like a huge
[ __ ]
so all right so where was i okay so
as we said before uh general butt naked
thought that being naked was um
you know like it was like magical powers
i mean magical thinking he said
basically he would just have shoes he
would have a gun he would have like
a couple of magical symbols like a
necklace or something somebody's asking
me a question so saddam hussein's
torture squad was filled
full of ted bundy and and andre
yes yeah yes that's exactly who they
were
um they called that special talent
which i guess that's [ __ ] what you
would call it yeah i guess
they were looking at it they recruited
special talent from from
out of prisons for their intelligence
community
and it makes you wonder if that's going
on here to a certain extent
i mean when you look at [ __ ]
epstein's island and weird [ __ ] like or
the or the
the child island man who did not kill
himself
and you already said girlfriend i know i
said it again i said
and the girlfriend of the child island
man who did not kill himself you know
there's the intelligence agencies of all
countries
are [ __ ] dangerous organizations if
you want to take over a country the
[ __ ] where you start is you start
with the intelligence organizations
if you take over the intelligence
organization you'll eventually take over
the country that's how saddam did it
that's how [ __ ] um uh uh stalin did
it
uh and it makes you wonder you know i
think i think other intelligence
agencies have done it to nations but
why show yourself why not just put a
[ __ ]
put a [ __ ] um what do you call it
a stand-in do you know what i mean to
rule for you
what do you call them um not patsies
like a puppet puppets yeah i i kind of
think
most intelligence agencies run most of
the countries through puppets that's
right that's how i think it mostly goes
but okay i was just laughing at dj
maniac's comment which was magical
things happen when i get naked too like
the police showing up
yeah yeah
oh my god all right so
yeah so all of his dudes like i said
they would wear crazy wigs they would
like carry purses
or they would run around naked uh he
also said
that they would always sacrifice a
victim before battle and this is a quote
usually it was a small child someone
whose fresh blood
would satisfy the devil yeah
he said this is how he said that he
caught them he said sometimes i would
enter under the water where children
were playing
i would dive under the water grab one
carry him under and break
his neck sometimes i'd cause accidents
sometimes i'd just slaughter them
so and like i said before he said that
he would take the kids hearts out
and he was very matter-of-fact about how
he did the [ __ ] like he would tie the
kid
to like a street light like or a pole or
something and then he would cut their
back seven with the machete and then
just like take the heart out through the
back
yeah because i guess it's easier almost
kind of like almost kind of like
the bloody like that's what i was
thinking that's exactly what i was
thinking
yeah so they so they would like take the
kid's heart out and they would like
share it they would like eat it because
they thought that it gave them magical
powers so
he said that between the ages of 11 like
i said when he said that he became a
tribal priest and at the age of 25
that he uh engaged in human sacrifices
once a month since the age of 12
11. yeah i think he's [ __ ] i think
so too like i said it's hard to
i think he's [ __ ] i think he's you
know i think he did a bunch of terrible
[ __ ]
but it's kind of like and like i said we
talked about a lot of serial killers on
the show where
it's bad enough that they do all the
horrible [ __ ] that they know that they
did
but then they kind of like try to
inflate their tallies and like try to
make it seem like they're
way more badass than they are they did
all this like other crazy [ __ ] that they
didn't actually do
um i'm like what you did was bad enough
you don't need to like exaggerate
plus it's almost kind of like i think
there might be a a confessional
effect you think yeah i killed 20
people and i don't really feel all that
good about it anymore
so i'm going to tell everybody i killed
200.
that way that way
i'm nowhere near as bad as everybody
thinks i am
you know what about yeah you know
they go man that's pretty bad and then
they go you know what
they think that's bad i really only did
one-tenth of that so i'm not that bad
yeah maybe it's that kind of thing where
you know you know what i mean when they
say you're like negotiating
yeah to like say that you'll like
you know the thing cost this much and
then everybody's like no but then
you tell them like how much you really
want for the thing it's kind of like
these girls like
oh let's see where this is going
let's see where this is going i'm gonna
tell them i sucked 100 dicks
but i didn't suck a hundred i only said
you know it's like
some [ __ ] like that i don't would any
girl say that no maybe back in high
school i don't know
i don't know no not even back then no
that's a dude thing does it do
because what what they have consistently
found out through sexual studies i mean
is that guys
guys over inflate and girls under
because you don't want to be the [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah
you know what i mean you don't want to
be a virgin either yeah
but there's still a double standard i
mean i don't know about now but i'm
talking about when i was in high school
like in the 80s and 90s it was all a
game though we knew it back then
yeah and it's it's just kind of like you
can't i mean
if some girl was like in high school and
she said that she'd slept with you know
x
amount of dudes even all the other girls
would think she was a hoe
you know what i mean so you had to like
downplay that [ __ ]
guys were like yeah i slept with you
know 400 women
like i lost count even if they were
still a virgin
yeah but girls you couldn't you had to
like downplay that [ __ ] number
you had to downplay that number so
that's why they can never really get an
accurate assessment
particularly with younger people it's
probably better now it was always the
good girls
the ones that seemed good on the surface
were always the ones that were getting
[ __ ] down
i do feel like the ones that got tagged
with that
like uh that you know that they were a
slaughterhouse or they were weird or
something like that usually that wasn't
the one
that usually wasn't the one yeah no
because i feel like that was like some
projection
so like all the good girls were like
well that's the [ __ ] over there so no
one will like
accuse me of being nice yes that's how
that game was the real [ __ ] was usually
one of those so-called good girls
oh yeah big time yeah big time hiding
that [ __ ] i mean not always
but a lot of times but a lot of times it
really did seem like yeah the one that
was kind of like [ __ ]
that you would never think was right the
total hope but yeah
so uh another thing that he said this is
another direct quote
uh from general butt naked he says
before leading my troops into battle
we would get drunk and drugged up
sacrifice a local teenager
like you do drink the blood then strip
down to our shoes and go into battle
wearing colorful wigs
and i love this and carrying imaginary
purses
we've looted from civilians imaginary
purses
that they looted from civilians so they
pretended to take purses
from people they were imaginary i don't
know
we'd slaughter anyone we saw chop their
heads off and use them as soccer balls
we renewed fearless drunk yet strategic
we killed hundreds of people
so many i lost count so
yeah so he basically said as you
mentioned earlier
that him being naked made him
essentially
invisible i don't think he meant
invisible invisible like nobody could
see him but invisible in the sense that
people couldn't like react quick enough
because they would basically just run
through the town either naked or wearing
wedding dresses or whatever
and would just like [ __ ] hack people
it's unclear what he means by invisible
that's what i'm saying i don't think he
means invisible like you can't see me
i don't think he means it like that it
could be what he's talking about is that
you run through the [ __ ] town butt
ass naked with machine guns and [ __ ]
women's wigs on and crap like that
people see you and turn away yeah
they don't see you because they look
away because you're you're naked they
don't want to see that [ __ ] [ __ ]
flopping around in the wind and then you
got a gun
so you can't look at them for very long
yeah maybe that's what
i don't know i'm trying to make sense
out of it and i don't think there was
any sense to it
yeah we're trying he might mean
when you don't have any clothes on you
can move
faster and your and people's eyes don't
linger on you as long
maybe that's what he means yeah i mean i
do kind of feel like
they can't get a bead on you yeah they
can't aim it i think that's
i mean it seemed like when he was
talking i think that's what he was
getting at like you're camouflaged
yeah well because like nobody wants like
i said if i saw some dude running naked
down the street i'm being like no
okay you put my pal ass out there i'll
[ __ ] [ __ ]
might be a factor i had a very funny
mental picture of
you just like running down the street
you'd like something out of [ __ ]
ghostbusters
you're not as pale as me that's for sure
i'd be catching all those african
bullets my white ass [ __ ] running
around through the [ __ ] town
be silhouetting me man [ __ ] light
hitting me jumping off like a [ __ ]
rainbow
yeah you would not be invisible
[Music]
fire him up look at his little perk [ __ ]
going down the street
so i think that [ __ ] only works i think
that [ __ ] only works in africa
between africans i get well it's i mean
you know
and they don't have i want to study it
more i'd like to have general butt naked
on it as a guest one of these days i'm
sure
we could probably get him on streaming
[ __ ] i don't know man
[ __ ] i'm flying down here and he can
stay in the [ __ ] guest room
imagine that uh
heading over there [ __ ] him drunk you
got me in some bad situations
i think that would be like the worst
situation without me
taking him out to the [ __ ] club
yeah oh my god it's like hey this guy
killed twenty thousand people their
hands around
like soccer balls yeah how do you feel
about that i'd like to hear all these
stories
good lord i [ __ ] i'd enter these
stories into like a [ __ ]
into like a dictionary like a you know
in
a battle tactics yeah asymmetric warfare
you know about how to fight naked
how many sacrifices you should do before
battle
all kinds of [ __ ] imagine he's a [ __ ]
wealth of [ __ ] knowledge
no african warfare sure african tribal
warfare
i mean i think it'd be interesting like
well yeah it'd be interesting
horrifying but interesting but that's
the thing like i said
you see some naked dude running towards
you with a big machete raised
that's not the only thing yeah you're
gonna be raised yeah you're gonna run
the opposite direction
i mean most normal people would yes i
think that's what it was i think
what he's talking about is that you're
[ __ ] butt ass naked you're [ __ ]
drunk
you've got a [ __ ] m16 he had three
thirty rounds you're clearly a crazy
person you're clearly [ __ ] crazy
i think it's a saucer he had three
[ __ ]
30 round magazines taped together and
you know what i mean
on in the [ __ ] magazine in the in the
in the
he had 90 rounds in the [ __ ] magwell
he had all kinds of necklaces on and
he's running towards the camera i'm sure
if you saw that
you'd [ __ ] turn and run so well from
your point of view
it's kind of like being invisible and it
breaks your nerve
you can't shoot at him so you can't
return fire
because you don't want to turn and face
it say just too frightening
you know well plus like i said his eyes
are probably bugging out because he's
all [ __ ] coked out and [ __ ] yeah
so yeah it's it's scary i think what
he's talking about is what we call
in the infantry [ __ ] gaining the
initiative
i think that's what he's talking about
gaining the initiative is what you have
is when you move first in other words
you get to drop on somebody
yeah and then you start shooting you you
achieve
fire superiority is what it's called
because you're shooting
shooting it's hard for people to shoot
back at you because
you're now in a two-way rifle range
you know a person's it's not
natural for a person to stand there and
get shot at
and return fire you know what i mean it
takes discipline to do that
so that's i think so he's interpreting
that as invisibility
yeah that's what he's talking about
achieving initiative
and excuse me obtaining the initiative
and achieving fire superiority on the
assault that's what he's talking about
yeah i get that yeah in other words
going
back ass [ __ ] wild and scaring the
[ __ ] out of people like i said because
because you look like a lunatic and
you're shooting yeah
and running towards you yeah you look
like so
it's difficult to return fire nobody
wants to deal with a lunatic because
they're unpredictable
right you don't know what they're gonna
do and he's charging you in a kamikaze
rush
you know and these guys aren't really
trying to deal with that
you know i mean they don't stand their
ground and [ __ ] deliver aim for
returning fire you know they're not
returning aim fire on the target they're
not taking cover so that's what they're
talking about
yeah that's what they're talking about
because it's funny i was watching some
uh
some other like uh you know shows about
interviews and stuff
i was reading some of the comments like
on youtube and somebody said you know
maybe there's something to that because
he was in all those
uh you know battles and [ __ ] like that
and he didn't he never got
shot he never got hurt so it's like
maybe there was something to it that he
was like running around naked
so like i said so during this first uh
liberian civil war you want another
drink uh yeah
i'm gonna make drinks i gotta make
drinks all right good we halfway through
this
uh probably roughly i don't know
we're talking about the [ __ ] but uh yeah
oh somebody somebody is going through a
hurricane oh my god
holy [ __ ] dude be safe out there i know
how that goes
i'm i'm not looking forward to [ __ ]
september because that's usually when we
have
ours i mean you know hurricane season
starts here june 1st but we usually
don't have
any until september that's when it
starts getting really bad
so uh during the first liberian civil
war which like i said was
in the early 90s um general butt naked
had
a little battalion of
mostly child soldiers or teenagers uh
they were known as the butt naked
brigade now this uh
this little group was funded by
roosevelt johnson
uh who was kind of like like i said
there were two different factions like
kind of
you know fighting for supremacy or
whatever in the country
uh so they uh also fought alongside the
united liberation movement of liberia
for democracy or
you limo if you want to be brief about
it
um so that was a militia now that was um
there was also a militia that was this
was the same militia that was led by
charles taylor prince you army johnson
um
and ulima was loyal to samuel doe who at
that time was
the president now the president was
later
taken prisoner by prince johnson
who was you know the rival faction and
they executed him like i said on tv
now in the documentary they kind of
showed
they didn't show the actual execution
but they showed
like the minute or two before that
because i was like please tell me
they're not gonna i mean the documentary
that we watched last night from 2011
they did show like a lot of like
dead kids like in the street and like
people
like laying down the street like big
things of blood and everything but i was
like please i don't i don't know if i
can [ __ ] handle watching
i've seen like at live executions before
and it's like not really a
something i would care to repeat so i'm
kind of glad they didn't show it but
i could imagine it and it was [ __ ] up
so they kind of show a little bit before
that but they don't show the actual
thing
now the civil war in liberia
um ended about 1996.
now as i said general butt naked who had
been loyal to samuel
doe who as i said was the president and
he was executed by the rival faction
so he was kind of um on the losing side
of the war
so what ended up happening now this is
his story like i said
everything he says you kind of kind of
take it with a grain of salt because i
don't know how much of this is
like him just kind of establishing his
narrative or myth making or whatever
but he says that he was right in the
middle
of sacrificing a little girl
um you know and cutting her heart out
and doing like i described before
and then he saw while he was doing that
like a glowing man like appeared behind
him
and it was jesus so he says that while
he was
sacrificing a little girl jesus appeared
to him
and basically said you know keep doing
what you're doing
and die or if you want to live then you
have to knock this [ __ ] off
and like repent for everything that you
did and you tell the story where you got
the girl
i don't know it was like all right i
know the story oh you know that story
okay
in the area he was operating he claims
that the little girl's mother gave him
the little girl
um as a sacrifice willingly as a
as a willing sacrifice that's messed up
yeah
to help him in battle he said it was
the most beautiful little girl he had
ever seen and she was very serene
when she went to the sacrificial altar i
wonder how much that is true though what
he said
and he said after he did that he that's
when he
he realized he couldn't you know he
couldn't do it anymore
yeah i think he had a moment of clarity
i think that's really what it was
that's kind of what it sounded like when
he was talking about it i mean
he said because he's written an
autobiography i haven't read it but he
did
uh he did write an autobiography and
i've read like excerpts of it
and he did say that it was while he was
in the middle of sacrifice he said that
he saw jesus like jesus appeared to him
like as a man
but he was like glowing like the sun
that's his explanation that's what he
said
i think that's apocryphal probably
he's trying to he's trying to um
explain his moment of clarity in
christian religious terms that's what i
believe yeah
i believe he sacrificed a pretty little
girl and afterwards like what the [ __ ]
am i what the [ __ ] am i doing
like he actually realized yeah which
like i said
not great should have not done that
stuff to start with but i was doing that
kind of [ __ ] before though
yeah um i do feel like
i'm trying to i'm casting back my mind
because i just keep thinking because i'm
like you know we always talk about
serial killers and that type of thing
have you ever heard of a serial killer
who later repented like for real i know
they all get like in prison
ed kemper's kind of said he did but did
he say he was sorry
about the same it's not really the same
i mean i didn't get the same vibe
because i do feel like serial killers a
lot of times like after they get
caught yeah and put in prison and then
they're like oh i found jesus like
please forgive me
and [ __ ] like that this to me doesn't
seem it's
similar but it doesn't seem there's a
big difference there's a big difference
with josh with joshua josh was never
imprisoned
he was starting to turn away from no
he's just running around loose yeah he
was starting to turn away from evil
when the war was still going on that's
very different
yeah okay i think what happened
is that he had killed too many people he
killed that little girl and then just
the course of the war
the way it was going i think he's
realized i think he realized that he
wasn't really fighting for
anything not anything good or anything
important
yeah and he just couldn't [ __ ] take
it and i
he had ptsd you have to under under
these circumstances
yeah i'm surprised like everybody so i
think he kind of had a country
he had like what you call a moment of
clarity he's just like
this can't continue this is [ __ ]
insane
so which like i said it's you know so
he come but later at one point for that
later on he
makes a mystical version of of of the
tail
to help spread the gospel
yeah you understand you know santa
tomorrow yeah yeah [ __ ] loaded so
[Laughter]
you're making sure that you make sure
i'm understood
yeah i know what you're talking about
that's what he that's what i believe he
did
yeah it's like i don't know a lot of
reality and communication is a lot how
you
frame things you know
and the version of events that he's
giving
now is beneficial to liberia and
the liberian people and it's to him too
yeah but i don't really see anything
wrong with that i think he's got a lot
weighing on him
i mean imagine if you kind of were doing
that [ __ ]
you know i mean kind of in a way out of
ignorance
and then you come to a moment of [ __ ]
realization that i'm [ __ ] insane
i'm doing some crazy ass [ __ ] this can't
be
you're gonna want to back off of that
yeah you don't really feel that great
about it you know
well i would hope not chances are
it could be that he was not what they
would
what they would call a self-actualized
person when all this [ __ ] was going on
and he somehow reached kind of like
maslow's
wait a minute hold on this has gone
wrong
yeah and and i think that's probably
what i have yeah drastically
yeah like this this has gone wrong i
gotta back off this
i don't know like i said this is very
hard for me because i was very very
conflicted like watching the [ __ ]
because
he's a product of the liberian ghetto
during the civil war
sure i get that it's a very special
place in time
and like i said i in a way too because i
write about serial killers a lot we talk
about serial killers a lot
i have sympathy for the children that
they once were because a lot of them
were
horribly abused yeah and you know i get
that
but the thing about it is that once
you're an adult
i feel like unless you have some kind of
mental illness
or some kind of something else that
makes you not
completely aware of what you're doing or
something like that i do feel like you
still
can make choices yeah and if i
understand what you're saying
you know what i'm saying but it's so
it's like that's like the last thing i
just can't a lot of people say is it
nature or is it or is it normal it's
about
because it's both it's it's a it's too
um it's too entwined to
really tease apart i believe i believe
that
josh was an african alpha male
all right he was a alpha liberian male
in that circumstance when that civil war
kicked off
that's what that environment created
and i think him and i don't think he was
too aware of
of how special the situation was in
library it was normal
to him well yeah that's what i mean all
this [ __ ] happening you know
and he's trying to up the ante and win
in this situation because you want to
win
because what else can you do yeah you
don't want to lose you want to win
so that's what it got built up into and
then eventually he's like
oh [ __ ] man this is some monstrous [ __ ]
i'm doing
yeah and like i said i mean fair play to
him
at least he realized that because i
guess that's right people don't
that's not the way a serial killer would
would react
yeah it's like the well the thing the
outcome went for
yeah the outcome is the same right but i
feel like the motivation behind it is
different
i'm totally different this is a lot of
peer pressure between
warrior males it's a lot of [ __ ]
happening at once i think it's
he it's environment and genetics
because he was kind of an alpha in that
situation that
of liberia at that time in place that's
what it created yeah
that's what rose to the i mean yeah and
like i said there are some situations
you know particularly at this time
period in liberia that are so shitty
yeah that it just creates me and maybe
if that hadn't been going on
if they never would happen if yeah if
they had been born somewhere else or if
their the situation had been different
like maybe none of that would have
happened it was the societal synergy
because i do feel like some serial
killers are
there's something wrong with them
specifically yeah because
some of them i mean some of them are
raised in really [ __ ] up situations
yes
but some of them come from relatively
normal backgrounds
uh and still are [ __ ] up so i do kind
of feel like that's a different
issue serial killers are genetic freaks
they're losers
all right joshua is a alpha
he's a [ __ ] good specimen genetically
he's got good intelligence he's big
he has a lot of charisma and leadership
skills yet you know what i mean this is
not a loser
yeah this is what won yeah in that
situation this is what rose to the top
uh is he culpable yeah but so was all
the [ __ ] liberia
yeah that's what was happening in
liberia yeah or at least everybody that
was like at the top
everybody at the top of the front chain
was because like i said a lot of people
that live there were just yeah they were
the innocent five-star
but they were the losers think about it
they were all getting killed
yeah that's not what was being selected
for success what was being selected for
success and power
was this yeah because there wasn't any
law in order
it was chaos yeah you just had small
militias like
fighting each other literal law of the
jungle literally and that's what rose to
the top
and it's really weird because i i didn't
even do this on purpose
but the movie review that went up
yesterday that uh the ninth
configuration yeah the william peter
bloody thing
that was kind of like the whole theme of
that movie too
was that this guy um you know the
character that was in it
he had done all these atrocities in
vietnam and the whole
question of that movie was even someone
as evil as that can they still be
redeemed
and the movie seemed to come down on the
side of yes
they could be and it wasn't even it was
a it was kind of religious but um
it you know in the sense that he did all
these horrible things but
then and he was like really mentally ill
but then he had like dissociated and he
was
trying to do good like he was trying to
help people like that were in the same
situation as him
yeah which i feel like is kind of
analogous to
what we're talking about now because
that's kind of like what
general butt naked did he was swept up
in this whole liberian civil war
thing he killed all these people these
horrible things he killed innocent
children
women everybody he just killed everybody
we considered them enemies though
and yeah and sacrificed them like you
know for magical because he thought it
gave him powers and stuff
once it was all over with once he was on
the losing side
you know once he kind of like came to
this understanding
he did and like i said
if it was self-serving i don't know but
he did come to a point where
he wanted to help the people that he did
go around and apologize to people that
he had killed their family members or he
had injured them
he did actually like try to help
the soldiers the child soldiers that had
fought for him that were now
rootless like now that the war was over
they didn't have anywhere to go they
didn't have any job skills they didn't
have any place to live a lot of them
were orphans
so he did actually seem to be trying to
help them
yeah um so he does seem to be trying
to you know make up for what he did
um so i guess that's kind of the best
you can hope for i mean it's a [ __ ] up
situation
you know the difference between
button your general butt naked and say
like a serial killer there's a big
difference
okay you could never trust a serial
killer
that's that's their [ __ ] sexual
orientation and those [ __ ]
that's yeah they're not like that
they're not doing it because of the
situation
they're they're very much in odds uh you
know
acting at odds with the civilians they
are uh total
[ __ ] misfits they're they're not
functioning properly there's
definitely something wrong with them
yeah general butt naked there's really
nothing wrong with them
he he's a high functioning individual
like i said
good leadership skills good quality he's
a good friend like a normal person
he is a normal person which is really
weird when you see him because
it's you you think of all the [ __ ] that
he did i wouldn't say he's normal he's
talented
he's a talented guy well like that's
what i mean he puts on a good [ __ ]
show when he's preaching in it
he's a he's above average it was the
situation he was a situational killer
he was a [ __ ] good african warrior
and what that required what rose to the
top
in in in in the times of the liberian
civil war was [ __ ] a ruthless
guy who believed in [ __ ] black magic
and
used terror as a weapon this is all very
primitive stuff
but it's really at the heart of all
warfare even organized warfare that you
know
that i was involved in really behind it
is just petty jealousy and greed
yeah you know of guys and corporations
pushing the war because hey you know
that that'll look good on that'll look
good on the quarterly urge
yeah so we just have a more
fancier way and a bigger you know what i
mean and we profit off of it more you
know
he's operating at the level of sage like
a small unit commander
like a sergeant yeah with you know he's
got his 15 guys and they're out there
trying to win these little battles
yeah like i said it was a he it was like
a small unit essentially like a small
one right he's operating at the conan
slash road warrior level kind of like
wes from [ __ ] road warrior that's who
you're dealing with
that's not that unusual a lot of guys
like that
and uh throughout history and a lot of
great men were like that through history
you know genghis khan was like that you
call him a great man or a terrible man
but
left his mark on in history um
gave birth to a lot of children so
genetically evidently it was success
we're all related his bad ass you know
what i mean
uh so he slung that dick around nature
kind of dictates what wins
and in liberia at that time guys like
general butt naked were winning
the situation changed and you know i
mean they got kind of the shitty end of
the stick
but that's the way the world works you
know well the world isn't fair and the
world doesn't care about it right and
warfare and warriors are temporary
warfare is temporary and warriors are
not monolithic they come and go
uh there's a time and place for
everything in that time of that time
passed
uh but the difference is is that i could
never sit down and [ __ ] hang out and
drink with a serial killer ever this is
[ __ ] disgusting [ __ ]
you couldn't [ __ ] trust him well yeah
because you never know
right but i could trust general butt
naked i'd have to drink a german butt
naked [ __ ] yeah i'd feel safe around
him
you know i don't know if you would but
to me that's just another fighter
i don't know it's hard for me to say oh
i probably would yeah he's all right
he seems to be all right he's not crazy
but i'm saying yeah he doesn't come
across as
as a weird or crazy no all that [ __ ]
that he did was
situational and it was part of the
culture and part of this
part of the the landscape of the battle
at that time
you know that's that's there's a lot of
dudes that did [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] in
vietnam
not only on the american side but on the
nva side and the kong side they did all
[ __ ] kinds of horrible [ __ ]
well yeah they went back to civilian
life and lived normal lives afterwards
it was caught up in them spirit at the
moment to me
yeah that's almost i'm not saying serial
killer's not scary but
that's like scary in a special way
because you don't well
because you don't know because like you
said some american soldiers and they did
know about this and some
like viet cong and stuff like that did
some really horrible [ __ ] like they
would wipe out like a whole village of
like women and children and stuff like
in a horrible way and torture them
marvin did that though uh republic of
vietnam did [ __ ] bad
well yeah but like i said that that's
what i'm saying everybody did everything
they did but the fact that
they could then come back and like eat
okay imagine you were the wife of
somebody that did
that and then they came back home and
you didn't know about it
and then they just totally went back to
life like nothing happened
like that's really scary to me you know
there's a battlefield synergy
of being there i get that and the scythe
is
the psychological temperature of the
[ __ ] participants
of the war at any given day could be
very different
you know what i mean like your buddy got
killed 15 minutes ago
you see some [ __ ] that got
captured [ __ ] that mother he
his friends did it you kill him that's
[ __ ] straight up murder
yeah all right but you forget about it
if you
let you cool off you know what i mean
and people that didn't have don't worry
about it
yeah you didn't know that person yeah
i mean but that is [ __ ] normal i know
that is very
but that's what i said that's scarier to
me because it's just so
all right here's another thing we're
going to talk about war crimes and
atrocities the united states army
conducted
all kinds of war crimes and atrocities
right around um uh auschwitz
when they found the [ __ ] camp of
auschwitz for about two days american
soldiers murdered germans
in that area german soldiers yeah
because they saw auschwitz
all right and they were mad yeah they're
mad they were disgusted well
as you might be should you try them for
war crimes
yeah the books see you're supposed to
try to work because they're going after
people that maybe didn't have anything
to do with it so
people get all high and mighty about all
this war crimes [ __ ]
these are men in uniform fighting and
killing each other
there's no crimes really okay there's
just war
war itself is a crime okay and there's
reprisals for [ __ ]
when they found auschwitz a lieutenant
colonel was in charge of it
american lieutenant colonel was in
charge of it and a general came in
and was trying to [ __ ] with what hell
was going
basically was trying to get newspaper
reporters and stuff into auschwitz and
was [ __ ] with us a lieutenant colonel
and slapped
one of the lieutenant colonel's privates
in the back of the head
for taking a swig out of a [ __ ]
bottle of [ __ ] whiskey because he was
[ __ ] they were looking at a damn
concentration camp all right
and that lieutenant colonel pulled a gun
on that general
and said if you ever touch another one
of my minimum blow your [ __ ] head off
they nearly killed each other 10
10 you know [ __ ] people were [ __ ]
pissed
you know what i mean evidently seeing a
concentration camp
was a mind-altering experience well i
get that all right i get that
it's that i don't you know it's like
millions cannot grasp
well that's the thing there's always
extenuating circumstances
you always have to take those into
account everything you know [ __ ] isn't
black and white
there's always something else behind it
that's why i'm interested in serial
killers and crimes and stuff like that
you have to like
why did they do it it's like you know
some people are just
evil and [ __ ] up and yes they should
just be like put down like a dog
i agree with that but it's like you
always have to look into the reasons
behind
why people did prejudice there are all
kinds of special circumstances
what was going on in liberia is extreme
yeah that's an extreme
like i said it's not good no one's
saying that i don't
see how anyone involved could have been
totally sane
after a certain period of time i mean
after finding auschwitz for about two
days american soldiers were murdering
germans
yeah these were war crimes some of these
german soldiers that were captured
american soldiers i can understand that
i'm not excusing it
i understand it high-ranking american
soldiers almost murdering each other
yeah over this concentration camp it
actually took general patton
and his army to come in and [ __ ]
order
everyone to shut the [ __ ] up and to
dissipate and he he
dismissed all those charges all charges
were dismissed
for everything and he said that you know
it was
he just pat was like it was temporary
insanity
yeah i get that i get that because like
i said the human brain can only
take deal with so much right um and like
i said i'm not excused because
like i said if if you or me or pookie or
somebody like that was like
an innocent bystander and we just got
killed because somebody was mad at
somebody that looked like me or
something like that
i mean obviously you know if somebody
shot me just because i looked like
somebody that made them mad you would be
upset
but i can understand why they do it you
know on the same
by the same token i can understand why
it happens i'm not excusing it i don't
think it's good
i think everybody just needs to chill
the [ __ ] out yeah and stop it
but it's like the more that i read about
this it's like this
case in particular and the documentary
that we watched last night which
i told them after it was over i was like
that made me feel so many like feelings
i don't really
know what i'm thinking right now um
because i was very conflicted about the
whole situation
um and you know reading about unsolved
murders and serial killers and stuff
every now and then i'll just kind of
like stop and think to myself i'm like
you know would it really
be so bad if like an asteroid just hit
the earth and like wiped us out because
i i just feel like let's start over
this is like really not it's not a good
thing i think i think part of the
problem
with what's going on is that people are
not properly educated or instructed
are instructed from early on exactly
what a human
is and what you know what i mean
humans humans are limited in what they
can do
and they do [ __ ] up [ __ ] sometimes
they do they do
everybody does it's kind of like part of
the situation
everybody and how humans react to
stressful situations it doesn't
now some people are saying well how do
you know what general butt naked was
doing it wasn't sexual for him maybe he
was
it's you know it well i don't think it
was i don't think it was when you
look at the me being me being an
ex-professional soldier i totally
recognize
what i'm seeing when i see the videos
and what
and when i'm hearing these stories i
know what they're talking about okay
they're not these are not professional
soldiers
they're in extreme situations um they're
under a lot of level they're under a lot
of stress
they're taking a lot of drugs uh they're
fighting and killing each other well and
the kids that he recruited a lot of them
were
orphans or you know they didn't have any
other prospects
yeah and then they're out there like
packs of [ __ ] wild dogs fighting each
other
and that's gonna create a certain kind
of [ __ ] synergy
and only a certain kinds of guys are
gonna survive that and rise to the top i
understand it
you know do i like it no i don't like it
you know but i understand it
it's something like out of mad max yeah
you know or it's like something out of
prehistoric times you know you're
talking about [ __ ] tribal [ __ ]
warfare that's exactly what it is
you know yeah uh it's but it's
that's human nature though human nature
isn't all good
it's there's a pack mentality in humans
that's why they survive
but yeah i don't know chips do it and
we're
we're animals like the other animals you
know yeah we're kind of between chimps
and bonobos yeah
but well that's the thing too it's like
i don't know i i kind of come at it from
it's i you know i was talking to him
last night and i was like i know you
kind of make fun of me for being like
all spock-like and [ __ ]
but i'm just i don't know i'm one of
those people that
i always i always wish that like humans
could just like
be better that just like knock that [ __ ]
off
you know what i mean because i feel like
it i feel like most people are
good or at least indifferent you know
what i mean most people wouldn't go out
of their way
to hurt somebody most people wouldn't
they just wouldn't because they don't
care enough to do that
so i do kind of feel like environment
has a lot to do with that that's
well yeah that too yeah i do feel like
people that have i mean particularly in
the west where
you know most people are privileged yeah
most people are very personal not
everybody obviously because there's a
lot of poverty predicting the united
states but
you know in the western world most
people compared to other parts of the
world are very privileged
so it's very easy to live a life where
you don't
come into contact with this with these
situations that
you know would cause you to you know
get into these kind of life or death
kind of decisions
so i get that i guess that it's like a
different thing to this situation we
have here would be say like
prisons and pirates okay
right very what was going on on the
ground in liberia would be very similar
to like what you would have in a prison
all right and also very similar to the
synergy going on with professional
pirates
yeah you know i mean in the 16th 1700s
you know pirates were very organized but
those [ __ ] were from prison a
lot of them
and you know or from navies and navies
at those times were basically prisons
too
and the private pirates were just
they were described as the enemies of
all mankind
yeah i mean i mean blackbeard gave his
[ __ ] wife to the crew
because they shared everything and this
weird [ __ ] that they did
well she insulted him over his socks and
she was the [ __ ] dog
maybe they were really ugly socks okay i
don't remember exactly what it was you
know she kept making fun of him because
he wouldn't [ __ ] change his socks or
something and she was the daughter of
the [ __ ] governor of puerto rico if i
remember correctly
and he was and she was like a high
society woman he was stuck he was sick
all her highfalutin ways so he gave her
over the crew to [ __ ] have sex with
and then then she's not mentioned again
and then he goes back out to see she was
probably gang-raped she did they did
they were the enemies of [ __ ] mankind
she she tried to civilize him you know
and she was showing him off to high
society because he's a famous pirate
and he was like [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ]
pirate we talking about you know
what you think is gonna happen yeah well
yeah it was i don't mean to victim blame
it's just that
i don't know what she was thinking well
she kept [ __ ] with him
about stuff like there's a particular
it's a very small percentage
of women okay because most women they
see some dude like that they're just
like yeah no thank you and they run the
other direction
but there is like a very small
percentage of women these are the same
types of women that
wrote to ted bundy in prison it's like
that guy i don't
i kind of get it in the way i don't get
it because i wouldn't do it because it's
[ __ ] up but
i think what they're trying to do
is they want to be the person
that is like this person has killed
multiple people
they are a terrible person i'm going to
be the one that's special enough
to change them i think that's
at the end of it the day i think that's
what it is i think they want to
it it's kind of like um they just want
to be this
this very special person that i'm the
only person that they're nice to i'm the
only person
that can like you said civilize them i
think that's where they're coming from
you can't do that obviously and please
don't try
but i think that's where the psychology
is i don't think it's that weird
um you know it is weird but it's not
that weird like i can understand
where even though i would never do that
i understand like where the psychology
is
ryan's in this in the in the chat saying
tom i want your shirt
uh i came up with this design jenny made
the design
and then i i produced it if you want one
of these shirts
just [ __ ] send me twenty dollars in
the super chat if you're in the
continent of the united states i'll send
you one out
and send us a private message because we
have a screen for that i got a screen i
can make a bunch of them
yeah and i'll make it in your size
and uh send me your address on facebook
or
where do you want to do it facebook or
you want facebook or email or email
and i'll send it to you you'll have it
in a couple of days
yeah like depending on because i have a
lot of extra shirts
yeah the only continental united states
i can't do it for 20 outside continental
united states because
the shipping is i mean shipping stuff to
the uk is usually about 25
yeah between 15 and 25 that's usually
because i think ireland is a little bit
cheaper that was 15.
but yeah so all right so
general butt naked he kind of like went
around on this thing until about 1996
civil war in liberia um
ends and then because he claimed he'd
seen jesus
apparently um he went to his uh
you know i guess he had like a higher up
commander so he went there he gave them
his gun and his machete or whatever and
said
you know i'm done fighting like jesus is
my commander now or god is my commander
now or something he's
he told them and he gave up all his
stuff
now there was another um church in
liberia
where there was another bishop there and
i guess he had been going there off and
on and that was another factor in his
like big conversion
um so he supposedly said that he fasted
for 54 days
and you know after he had seen jesus and
everything so now it's like this big
narrative where
if someone is evil as me can be redeemed
and if jesus
still says that i'm you know redeemable
and god still calls me his son and
everything
then he can fix you too
so that's kind of what that's where he's
coming from with his sermons nowadays
is that if god can forgive someone as
horrible as me
then he should have no problem forgiving
you also
which like i said that is a very common
it's a very common thing in evangelical
circles because
you know how there's a big um it's
almost like a cliche at this point
but i feel like in evangelical circles
if you
tell them that you used to be a satanist
and that you used to sacrifice dogs and
cats or children or whatever or babies
or whatever
and then you found the lord and blah
blah they will
buy that [ __ ] and put you around on the
[ __ ]
circuit yeah hold on one second uh i
think dj man
dj you sent maniac did you send me some
money or something
i think he's asking for a shirt yeah i
think did he say
he might have i'll have to look like
back in the past uh
yeah if you said if you sent me some
money then um
just send us your address i'll send you
a shirt yeah and like what size you want
right it might take a couple weeks
because if we don't have that size i
have to order a blank i take it you want
a plisten shirt
i got three other ones i got one with a
13 o'clock one
which is really cool a new one and i got
a wayland industries one
and a weyland yutani sure from the
aliens i got and it has 13 o'clock on
the back
so i got those but yeah but the new
shirts are [ __ ] awesome
they're the best shirts we've ever had
yeah they did actually come out really
good i thought and i ordered like a
whole bunch of shirts but my
my pliskin shirt you know idea man
that's my favorite one so far [ __ ] i
like this one
this is what i originally wanted this
this [ __ ] here
is [ __ ] bootleg as a [ __ ]
because that's the ford cobra
it is logo that's what i wanted we'll
show them the back too because it has
like a little 13 o'clock look
on the back see yeah can they see it
yeah i think well like i said there's a
lag so yeah i can't believe this whole
thing is lagging like
it's lagging like two seconds behind so
it's like throwing me out
couldn't do anything online with the
ford cobra [ __ ] logo because that's a
copyright violation but you see i can
bootleg them i'm making them by hand
yeah we just make them and i don't sell
them it's just
[Laughter]
but yeah i'm pretty sure he has i'll go
back and like look at the super chats
but yeah
but like i said give me your uh address
and what size you want stuff
and we'll make you one because i got to
do another mail out anyway patrons are
all getting a new 13 o'clock one
yeah do we have one printed up i can
show them yeah there's one back there
like hanging on the chair
yeah that was one that we kind of messed
up a couple of the heavy hitters
people that gave us a lot of money over
time
they're getting a pliskin shirt also
some people got two
there we go okay put it in the thing
yeah down a little bit down a little bit
the lag is so bad i know like it's
really bothering me
that's what it looks like yeah
i really like how that came out actually
we made some for ourselves as well
but yeah that's the one we sent out
you saw the hat yeah i got my vietnam
tiger stripe on
you look i was going to say you looked
at my tiger stripe you look like you
need to be
like fighting the predator yep
so all right so when the uh civil wars
came to an end
like i said in the mid to late 1990s
uh because general met naked had been
a commander for the losing side in the
war
he ended up having to flee to ghana
and he lived in a refugee camp there for
a while
and this is where he kind of um you know
had his
big conversion officially or whatever
um he did say that
he that he goes around like talking to
victims of uh you know his atrocities
and
relatives of his atrocities and says he
feels really bad about it
um at various times he has said that he
was
possessed by satanic powers at the time
because like i said he thought that the
deity that he was sacrificing to
he later identified it with the devil so
that's another thing that bothers me
because
it does feel like he's trying to dodge
responsibility a little bit
in the way that he's saying well the
devil made me do it essentially i don't
think that's what he means
i think what he means is is that he was
of course overcome with [ __ ] negative
emotions and hatred
it feels like you're possessed by the
devil
you're pissed off [ __ ] you know what
i mean bloodlust and stuff that's what
he's talking about
yeah but he's gonna he's gonna gonna
rationalize that
and and turn that into a mythology you
know what i mean
it's like being possessed by the devil
i've noticed that what he says
is not literal everything is figurative
and he speaks he speaks mythologically
yeah you know you're not talking about a
western scientific [ __ ]
analytical mind that's not what's going
on this is all emotion
it's all emotion it's magic
yeah magical thinking yeah that's
exactly yeah he's not on spock level
he's on kirk level
as we've mentioned before that's the
dynamic here as well
he makes fun of me for being spockled
which which is very funny that you came
up with that because my ex-husband used
to call me spock as well
yeah isn't that very funny you're trying
to find
objective truth there's no objectivity
in what he's talking about everything is
subjective it's all subjective stuff
you know but the thing about it is that
i think
that and we were talking about this a
little bit last night i was like i think
you think that because i'm spock-like
that i don't understand that i do like
i do i just don't i don't feel the same
way
as that so i don't like
relate but i understand it you haven't
been out there fighting
but i understand it though i get it yeah
understanding and [ __ ] going well
because
yes i mean i can imagine what it would
be like
i can imagine putting myself in someone
else's shoes putting myself in someone
else's situation how would i
react in that situation how would i feel
in that situation so i get that
imagine there are some dudes that evil
[ __ ] trying to kill you
all right and you say man i gotta become
a badass in order to survive this yeah i
get that so then you just become a
[ __ ] badass then you start winning
and you like it you see i killed those
[ __ ] who were trying to kill me
he goes where are the next ones you know
and then more of them are coming
because the more enemies you kill the
more enemies rise up against
you so your problems start to multiply
well you're now in the game
okay so you start to become more and
more of a badass to overcome this wave
as human wave of [ __ ] enemies
and the more of them that you knock down
the more fierce you become
and then you start having problems
differentiating between friend and enemy
well yeah they're in that direction so
they're all
enemy you know he didn't help me so he's
an enemy so i'm just gonna stop i'm
gonna kill
you [ __ ] if you're either with me or
against me if you're not in my unit
you're not one of my commandos then
you're the [ __ ] enemy
that's eventually what it kind of turns
into yeah i know you weak ass
[ __ ] aren't helping us
die [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what that's
that's what it is
like i would never do that because i'm
not like that you're not interested but
i
but i get it and they start getting
breath they start living in hatred
you know they start to hate and despise
weakness
yeah i'm fighting for survival and you
weak [ __ ] can't help me die
you know yeah that's what exactly what
they're doing they become that
[ __ ] right back there
they become that [ __ ] right back
there
that's what happened i would probably be
like that if it wasn't so much work i'm
too lazy to be a mass murderer
[Laughter]
i mean i have a moral compass too i'm
just saying but all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
goes away when they're trying to kill
you but like i said i get that
i get that like i said i can't put
myself in other people's
shoes i can't put myself in other
people's situation
and think of how i would react in that
situation so i get it
so it's like not alien or anything like
that pray
this synergy does not start to grow here
in the united states i'm just going to
leave it at that
i don't want to go down on one of my
[ __ ] tire rates yeah don't go on one
of your tires
the soil you'll be all right the soil is
fertile for it
okay go ahead somebody says they missed
the itty bitty kitty intermission
yeah because i'm not editing these
anymore so i don't like have videos to
put her although
we did make little i took some pictures
of her like playing with the box that
nancy sent
yeah like trying to like getting in the
uh sleeping bag and stuff
so maybe i'll say something level shirt
please
are you spock level or kirk level yeah
this is ryan schwartz talking about this
requesting more shirts ryan you haven't
paid me for the first shirt
give me his address like where to send
them
you haven't paid me ryan you want a
shirt man you got to [ __ ] send me 20
bucks bro and then send me your
true address well like i said i need
addresses and sizes also yeah not in the
chat section sent it later on [ __ ]
yeah
on facebook you should do the kitty
intermission again but include our baby
books yeah she's
where did she go she was in here for a
little while because i heard her like
[ __ ] around back there trying to get
in the box again yeah
but yeah so so later on
joshua aka general buck butt naked
starts
the end time train evangelistic
ministries etc in incorporated
end time trained evangelist evangelistic
ministry yeah
that's what it's called yeah they think
it's end times yeah
so yeah well that's what i mean so their
line of thinking is very much in line
with some kind of fringe
christian fundamentalist christian
groups evangelical christian groups in
the united states
that think that we're in the end times
and
like i said they love a repentant sinner
yeah if they love that [ __ ] so much yeah
but we gotta point some [ __ ] out
all right i have a christian background
you know what i mean
i don't have anything against the
christians i'm i'm a mythicist
actually i'm and i'm a christ mythicist
which i can get into the story
the difference between an american
church and an african church is very
large okay they're not talking about the
same
things all the time in africa i would
think it's a lot closer to end times
you know what i mean what's going on
then would be here
from their point of view those
apocalyptic
images would probably seem a lot more
real
i can understand them believe in that a
lot more than
somebody here than americans here
although some people say you know this
is the rise of the antichrist and this
and that but i
we went through we went through
revelations
that has been
revolution has a lot of great imagery in
it i [ __ ] love revelations
that prophecy hard
that prophecy was about rome it's not
about us
and yeah you could say well it sounds a
lot like and this and
yeah but you can do that a lot about a
lot of prophecy and it's not about us
a lot of the things that are talked
about in that prophecy are combos kind
of universals
but then some of some of it specifically
talks about
rome and the roman city yeah they're not
talking about
modern times they're talking about the
end of the roman empire in the beginning
of the [ __ ] christian
well here's the thing here here's what i
always think of and it is a false and
it's false it didn't happen
the battle of megiddo did not happen
yeah because it didn't happen to
and rome didn't really fall all right
in the way that it's described there
rome became the first
christian civilization so
you could say the prophecy was not true
you know jesus didn't come back and
destroy rome
rome became christian it's a big
difference
yeah i well i think the thing about it
is that we
when you look back at history when you
for example we use the phrase the fall
of rome
but it sounds like it was like an
immediate no it took 200 years you know
it's just kind of like when people talk
about the death of the dinosaurs
for example to take an evolutionary
example i mean that took
a while it wasn't ju it wasn't immediate
yeah
it was just like some bad [ __ ] hit the
earth it was like some climate [ __ ] it's
like you know it took a while for that
[ __ ] to happen
it's just we're not good at
extrapolating because we
we're so used our our lifespans are so
short yeah
that we're so used to everything
happening like rome didn't really
fall rome split into two an eastern and
western empire the western empire
declined and morphed into [ __ ] the
medieval era
and the eastern empire ended up becoming
byzantium all right when that lived for
a long time almost until world war one
there actually you could say that it was
the ottoman it became the ottoman empire
you know in some ways it it was not a
single
cataclysmic event as described in in
revelation
it didn't happen that's what i mean it's
just like in a way it wasn't even a
i mean it wasn't even a fall in this
it's just like an evolution
of yeah i mean it just went into
something else it wasn't like some big
huge [ __ ] disaster i'm gonna say it
was a decline
right all right a lot of that great
artwork and science [ __ ] evaporated
over time and the
you know what i mean those statues
became [ __ ] i mean a true
greco-roman statue looked like a [ __ ]
photograph
that's how good it was and that was lost
for 1500 years
think of that yeah 1500 years they
couldn't they couldn't reproduce that
that's what i mean that's like
that's that's a long [ __ ] time you
can see
us an expensive statue of a roman
emperor
and you can feel that motherfucker's
soul coming out of it that's
it was like a photograph like a hologram
that's how good they were
you could i could get a feeling of who
those dudes were yeah
even though it was probably you know
propaganda you know what i mean [ __ ]
well
everybody they're not gonna like they're
not gonna do it makes them look like
they really look
but aren't they some of that stuff
everybody wants to look pretty yeah
but some of those guys [ __ ] and i
always got this feeling of like
a [ __ ] who was almost kind of
like the sith it was like a
a master of good and evil yeah i mean
like a dude who could
who could use the stick and the carrot
on you he wasn't quite good he was like
a mixture
of good and evil you know i kind of
respected the romans
which i guess most people are they were
like glorified gangsters but [ __ ]
real
[ __ ] intellectual using latin like a
[ __ ]
weapon weaponized latin on you
you read that not writing you know
you're like [ __ ] those dudes because
dudes were smart man well some of it
some of the [ __ ] from back then if you
read like an english translation of it
it almost sounds like something that was
like today
now but a smart [ __ ] from today
like you know
that's what i mean that's that's what
kills me about people that have this
weird conception that like ancient
people were dumb i'm like
at least not over there not at all the
elites were [ __ ] super smart
and crafty well like i said some of the
[ __ ] if you read an english translation
some of it you wouldn't know that that
was written thousands of years ago
star trek the original series they had a
damn
episode where they go to apparel another
planet that's a lot like
rome and a starship captain ends up
being enslaved by
by their emperor and he tells kirk he
says james
they're better than us and that's
exactly what they were talking about
dude was using all those weasley ways to
get people to kill each other
yeah because they didn't have any moral
boundaries everything was just about
full spectrum you know i mean full
spectrum behavior they're like gangsters
no you know you guys might remember that
episode
that's weird i love that episode the old
star trek was very educational
i still love the originals the original
series is very educational the other
ones are good too
but yeah i really liked the writing on
the old ones guys like the original
series man go see star trek continues
free on [ __ ] youtube i like they had
the [ __ ]
part two of [ __ ] the mirror episode
with the evil spock with the [ __ ]
beard man that that [ __ ] episode is
bad
ass evil spock was so evil spock yeah
can we mention that grant in the heart
grant my heart
he's in that he's in star trek continues
because
you [ __ ] believe that he was so young
yeah that happens
that's messed up all right somebody
asked um
do we still have beijing yes we do yes
she just never wants to be on the show
how old is she now 10 10 or 11.
she's uh a princess yeah and she
is very aloof she very rarely
comes in here when we're doing anything
yeah she doesn't [ __ ] around
she mostly just wants to do her own
thing um pookie is very different pookie
is very like wants to get involved in
everything all the time but beijing is
not like that at all she's just like
[ __ ] people i'm going over here
i'm gonna go be fabulous like on my
little scratchy chair that she lays on
she just lays there looking like the
queen also somebody asked earlier
have we seen uh ghost killers versus
bloody mary yes we did
and we actually posted a review of it
yeah great movie
days ago great yeah i liked it very much
it was very good brazilian flick
yeah that's brazilian movie i've seen
and be i know i i speak
and understand well i understand
portuguese fluently i don't speak it as
well as i used to because i don't use it
as much anymore
and i have the i have the functional
vocabulary of a 16 year old because
that's how old i was when i left brazil
but
the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
portuguese dialogue is [ __ ] hilarious
[ __ ] hilarious
and the subtitles are accurate that's
that's what they're saying that was a
funny
yeah it's a good movie i mean if you're
into it's very crass and it's very gross
and it's very like if you're into like
evil dead
it's very brazilian or yeah or um dead
alive or something like
that then it would probably be right up
your alley i mean because it's like a
horror comedy that's like super
i mean there's poop there's puke there's
gore
there's it's disgusting yeah but it's
super fun yeah
but yeah we did a review of it not pc at
all
it is [ __ ] brazilian you'll see it's
good
it's [ __ ] funny brazilian humor is a
punch to the [ __ ] face
all right it's kind of like very
old-school american humor
um everything is fair game and this
movie [ __ ] didn't pull any punches
it's good
yeah i liked it a lot yeah i thought i
was a blast yeah but yeah so
yeah so he started this church um like i
said he's got a wife he's got four kids
but and they went into this a little bit
in the
documentary which they made in 2011. um
when he kind of took off for ghana
because
i guess he was afraid that he was gonna
get in trouble or he was gonna
you know be bought brought before a
tribunal or whatever
so he runs up to ghana for a little
while everyone kind of got pissed at him
including his family
his family and like all of the uh you
know now grown child soldiers that had
been underneath him
that he had been helping out they kind
of felt like he abandoned them for a
time because he was in ghana for
a while like for several years he was
like kind of hiding out over there like
in a refugee camp
so i can kind of understand though they
went yeah from their word
true you know what i mean they said that
he was good to go and that they weren't
gonna mess with him
but changing political scenes they went
back on their agreement with him so
i wouldn't trust any of those
governments down there either i mean
would you
i wouldn't well i i don't trust anybody
yeah anything
for any reason every few years that's a
different regime
in there you know what i mean yeah you
never know what's gonna happen it's just
kind of right
and and they're all enemies of each
other so you know
but um he does apparently like i said he
is
even though there is some controversy
over
whether he's using the funds for what
they were intended to or not
but he does have um an ngo called
journeys against violence and he uses it
to train
his ex-child soldiers and um you know
other kids that grew up in the street
they were like just drug addicts or
whatever
and they don't have any prospects so he
does seem to be trying to
give them drug training he was at one
point with
funding from some american evangelical
christians
they were trying to build a center with
like a computer center
they were gonna do like like you know in
job training
type programs he gave them the thing
about it though is that
he paid for them to all take um
driving tests and like get their
driver's license but
none of them had the money to get cars
so
they couldn't really use the driver's
licenses at that point
so like i said there's kind of this
whole controversy over whether
because i i think the last thing i read
was that
his kind of supporters over here were
giving him
between like 800 and twelve hundred
dollars a
month well that's a lot of money which
for yeah because like they're like for
average like people that work over there
get like 38
a month like equivalent so it's a lot of
money
um so he's getting a lot of that and it
seems like he's
taking half but then he's taking like
maybe more than that
like for himself and not using it for
what it's intended for but i don't know
if that's true or not
like because he does seem to be opening
up some types of things where he's
trying to make some kind of restitution
about like the
you know the people that he pressed into
service like there's a lot of corruption
down there too
so yeah right exactly it could be to do
anything you have to grease a lot of
palms
and that would be the case sure and you
probably also have to pay
to to grease palms to keep your ass from
[ __ ] getting killed or put into
prison too so
a lot of that money is probably being
used to grease grease palms to get [ __ ]
to happen
corrupt as [ __ ] real corrupt it's weird
though because
even in the documentary and i don't know
about nowadays because the documentary
came out nine years ago
but when they showed him just like
walking around
in liberia i mean everybody knew who he
was because he's very famous
um a lot of people would just like come
up and like
hug him or be like hey general or
whatever
so well depending on what side of war
you were on he was either a hero or a
villain so
right you know one man's hero was
another man's villain
yeah so you know some people liked him
yeah so he doesn't really seem to be
getting a lot of pushback i mean it does
seem like he they did show him going and
visiting like he visited the one guy
that they called the senegalese
um who who general butt naked had shot
it
shot his legs off yeah um and
that guy he seemed like initially
reluctant to like want to talk to him
and he
was really kind of like man [ __ ] this
[ __ ] or whatever but then like finally
he was like okay
i forgive you and that guy died later
right
i think he did he did die i think he
died of tuberculosis
and um you know joshua did seem like
upset about that and he did go to that
woman's house and like you know
he had killed her husband and you know
she later kind of went
but she seemed a little conflicted about
it too like she went
in front of the congregation and he was
like yeah i killed her husband and here
she is and blah blah
she said later she's like i didn't
really like when he called me up there i
didn't really want to go
but you know i kind of had to so she was
like conflicted about it too so like i
said that's why this
documentary like give me a lot of
feelings because it's really it's a
really
good documentary it's a really good
document you can get it on on youtube
or on yeah i think it's like xbox 399
399 it's worth watching it's a trip it's
really good
it's i mean it goes more into it doesn't
go
i mean it talks about his atrocities and
stuff but it goes more into
him trying to make him trying to make
amends and like his evangelical
kind of stuff like the later [ __ ] that
happened yeah he goes more into that
it's weird because he'll approach these
people where he
murdered their whole family and you can
see like man they're [ __ ] super
uncomfortable around this guy
yeah like you can see it in their faces
he starts talking to him and [ __ ] you
know what i mean
it's weird and then the next thing you
know they're walking down walking
holding hands and [ __ ] going to church
with him it's
[ __ ] bizarre because that's what i
was thinking like i was thinking this
that whole
like that whole like um last 20 minutes
of the documentary
yeah i'm sitting there like putting
myself into this woman's shoes i'm like
how would i feel
if this had happened to me like what if
some dude like a warlord or whatever
like maybe i lived in some [ __ ] up
situation or whatever
and came in and killed you and killed
pookie and killed myself
and then like 20 years later he comes
back and goes comes back and says i'm
sorry about it
see i don't think i would i
don't think i just wouldn't maybe i'm a
terrible person i don't know i'm not a
i'm not a real forgiving person is one
thing
um you know what i mean i'm not a
christian i don't do that whole like
turn the other cheek kind of [ __ ]
i'm like i feel like if you did some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you need to own that
and i don't have to forgive you and i'm
not going to and i know that you want me
to forgive you so i'm not going to just
despite you because i'm an [ __ ]
well he says that yeah he says you
shouldn't forgive me
if you don't forgive me i understand it
yeah he knows you know and probably i
wouldn't and i and i for real would not
go up because like i said i don't i
don't play with that whole
evangelical [ __ ] so i for real would not
go in front of someone else's
congregation and try to like get
it's my opinion that that the whole
christian angle
is actually just part of it that's
i think that's more of the the pr angle
i think he does want to put all that
behind him and i think he wants to
[ __ ]
take that load off of him you know what
i mean and i think he does want to try
to
smooth things over i think if he could
reverse it he would
i mean it's kind of like what they tell
you to do there's nothing he can do like
in alcoholics anonymous where they say
that's one of the step
like 12 steps is that you're supposed to
go like make amends so like all the
people you [ __ ] i mean how the [ __ ]
can you how the [ __ ] are you gonna do
that you can't understand you can't not
do that like i get that
he says that you know what i mean he
knows that he can but if he could
undo it he would i can tell he would
i think it was kind of like a temporary
insanity
wartime temporary insanity that's the
thing though it's like i get that
i understand that i do but it doesn't
make it better
like it doesn't make it better because
like i said if it happened to me
i'm like that's still my family that's
still my kids it's just one other thing
it's just one of the things that you
know you got to put it down
it's in the past yeah what are you gonna
do kill him
and that's the thing that's why this
documentary made me feel so many
feelings because
like would i feel better if i got to cut
off his head
and like put it on a stick probably
wouldn't
maybe he would i don't know i think i
might maybe he would i'm a terrible
person the thing is though
is is that the same dude i'm not sure
that's even the same dude
because these changed a lot it was 20
years ago see this gave me like so many
moral quandaries yeah that's [ __ ]
it's not quite the same dude i mean he
was a lot younger when that [ __ ]
happened that's the thing it's like i
like to think that i'm a good person
right
but if somebody did some really [ __ ]
up [ __ ] to me
and they like for real it came to me and
i thought they were really being
contrite and they were really sorry for
what they did
i still think that now i think i still
want to cut out i think that general
butt naked is gone
i think that was a temporary thing maybe
and uh i just i don't know i i don't
know if i can either
get on board i think the general i think
general butt naked was kind of like a
wartime larping personality
that went away and died with the war
that's what i think happened
i don't think that was sustainable
mental
[ __ ] me i don't think it was just a
sustainable mental state
yeah he had that moment of clarity and
then he's just like oh this ain't me
i think that's what and then like you
said the circumstances and the
circumstances changed but the thing
about it though is that
yeah there's that that's an extenuating
circumstance but there's also the fact
that
once you've done something you can't
undo it yeah
and all of those people that he killed
had families
that are now i mean that person's dead
forever they're never coming back
so it's like you can't fix that no you
can't fix it
and here's the deal you killed general
butt naked
but what about the all the other ones
that are still out there running around
and then all the other [ __ ] soldiers
that were underneath them that were
doing the same [ __ ]
there's thousands of them that's what i
mean it's such a [ __ ] up situation
is it better because they talk to a lot
of people that you know live there in
uh you know in the capitol or whatever
and they were like they didn't really
see any
value in executing
these people because they're like look
everybody just wants to put the [ __ ]
behind that
yeah and move forward and it's like
doing that it's just gonna put us back
in that mindset
even though even though innocent people
were being killed
women and children all right a lot of
[ __ ] was
was reprisals for [ __ ] that the other
sides did
too yeah and so it was wartime they were
all killing each other
right yeah i mean hatred just kind of
took over
that's what i mean it's just this yeah
and so
i don't want to say everybody got what
they deserved it's just that
peace came out of that eventually so
probably best thing to do is just kind
of
let it all try to be forgotten as much
as possible and let those generations
die off
that's probably the safest thing to do
if you go out and try to hunt down all
those dudes the wars will just break out
again
yeah because then yeah i like i said
from a larger
you know coming at it from a larger like
societal standpoint
it's like you probably you know yes
everybody wants
justice everybody wants you know
retribution for what happened i get that
but it's like is that really going to be
moving forward because i do feel like
everybody just wants to
put that behind not forget about it but
put it behind them and like move on to
something
and this is all happening in a society
that has no rule of law
yeah liberia at that time was [ __ ]
without any kind of rule of law there
was no government it was [ __ ] mad max
it's just kind of like it's interesting
because i hadn't really thought
about a lot about this guy pretty much
those you know what else is notice i
forgot to tell you but
they had no rule law back then and no
investigative [ __ ] ability
one guy who was a [ __ ] war criminal
said how are you going to convict me
there's no evidence all that shit's gone
yeah
they had no evidence and there was a
even though he said he did it
well yeah he was very openly admitted
that wasn't one of the other warlords
it's like how can you convict me all the
evidence is gone
he goes like you know any fair trial you
need
evidence and all these [ __ ] witness
testimony and you have to be able to
prove it he says
that was 20 years ago all that shit's
gone there was no government then
so you'd be convicting people based on
unreliable witness testimony
which is [ __ ] that's what i mean it's
[ __ ] chaos
brought up so many like moral conundrums
for me because i was just kind of like
i don't know like how do i feel about
this because
what he did was so messed up and
what other people did in that situation
was messed up should he be punished for
it probably
um you know i i don't think people
should get away with that kind of [ __ ]
but at this point if we don't think he's
gonna do it again like i said it's not
like a serial killer situation where you
think
yeah we have to like lock them away or
like put them down like a dog because
they're not gonna
change because i think that's a
different situation
if you don't think he's gonna do the
[ __ ] again is it really productive like
you said to
make an example of him maybe
as much as people might want to i will
say though that i do admire
people that can forgive someone that did
someone like that that did something to
them directly um
even because [ __ ] man i've seen people
that
you know their daughters or their wives
or something like that were killed by
serial killers even
and they even stood up at the [ __ ]
trial and said that they forgave the
person and i'm like well
you're clearly a better person than i am
because i would never ever do that in a
million
[ __ ] years ever so i do kind of feel
like
i mean i'm not gonna let it like bog
down my whole life i'm not
you know it's i would move on with my
life and like live a normal life but
i would never forgive that person why
would i
i'm this i'm reading the [ __ ] you know
what i mean yeah i'm reading all the
[ __ ] comment sections they were like
well what is he actually accused of what
kind of warcraft
[ __ ] law and order [ __ ] broke down
all right
the president of liberia was [ __ ]
tortured to death on live television
yep warlords started to [ __ ]
break out fighting each other all over
the [ __ ] they would just basically go
through towns and just
shoot or machete yeah everybody like
everybody
the [ __ ] little kids women everybody
it was widespread mass
murder on all [ __ ] sides they were
just it was like sacrifice
human sacrifice hannibal warfare sure
cannibalism
everything this was not a [ __ ] normal
civilization
normal situation for a civilization to
go through
it was just a breakdown of [ __ ] also
it was mad max
all right there wasn't any law at that
time
yeah that's what happened all right a
lot of people were involved in it
too many people were involved in it to
kind of really be brought to justice
and all the evidence is long gone
pretty much everybody was kind of
involved in it to some some degree or
another unless you were maybe like women
and children
or old men well that's kind of one of
the arguments that they were making
it was widespread i mean if we made an
example of him it's like we'd have to
make an example of
you know of thousands and thousands of
thousands of other people
and fighting would start break out
because really there wasn't
any legitimate law who's gonna [ __ ]
hold these
trials your enemies people that hate you
there was no neutral parties
yeah all right so that's that's what
happened and then other guys are saying
well if he really
regretted it he wouldn't be able to cope
no no that's not the way that's not the
way things actually work
a lot of what he did was actually on par
with
what other people were doing those guys
never came
for never never came forward or said
anything
they just went into hiding there's lots
of them
general butt naked was really the only
one that
went before them said yeah and they
admitted that
i'm guilty like i said i respect that
that he
actually had the balls to do that yeah
and he actually
took credit for killing more people than
he actually did
so i think he did have a change of heart
um but you can't really reverse
what happened yeah yeah and
giving the guy a fair trial would be
damn near impossible
who would who would who would who would
you know
they were all guilty a lot of them you
know and and you have a thing too
where i mean he's become at this point
because it was i mean the liberian civil
war so long ago
i mean it ended in the mid 90s that
you're gonna get
two opposing factions you're gonna get
like
people that will just hate him no matter
what and people who
see him as i said like a phone call
everything's polarized
right and like i said it's and some of
those people have
there's no impartiality there i mean
some of those people have reason to
think of him in that way because
you know maybe they fought for him when
they were a child and then like he
helped him out later on like he taught
me to drive he got me a job he
you know gave me a place to live wanted
to have one it's like some of the kids
that were under his care
were living there was this set of twins
that were in his army when they were
kids
they were living in a [ __ ] they slept
in a grave
in a graveyard that they had dug out
they were orphans they didn't have
anywhere to go
and he actually gave them a place to let
he gave them a bed and [ __ ] like that
so it's kind of like you know those
people are always going to be and you
could see it like in the documentary
that he had like a core group of people
around him
that had fought for him and you know
back in the day when they were kids and
obviously they knew that that was bad
and like you know they shouldn't do that
anymore
but they idolized him he was their
father figure a lot of them were orphans
or were street kids
like and they they were like well he got
us off drugs and he got us
you know he made us useful he gave us a
job he did
we're not saying he's a good man no he's
not he never said that he said he was a
mixture of good and evil
and the guys who served under him now
says he was mostly evil
back in the war and now he's about 75
percent good 25 percent evil
yeah that's what that one guy said he
said but everybody's a mixture
now he's not the only one you know he's
not like the hitler
of [ __ ] liberia they were all like
this
all right though he's the only one that
actually [ __ ] came
forward and said i'm guilty i killed a
whole bunch of [ __ ] people in the
civil war blah blah blah killed twenty
thousand would you lied
he didn't kill that man i think he's
respond he thinks he's responsible for
that
all the other ones [ __ ] hightail that
they're they're [ __ ] hiding
and one thing i will they don't say [ __ ]
he did say that he was willing to go
before the hague if they wanted him to
yeah and would
he was willing to pay for it he was
willing and because of that
because he was the only one that
actually kind of came forward to the war
truck crime
tribunal they said well we're not
looking for you
you know good they told him to go
because he was just one of many
that were like that well like i said in
a situation like that if it's gonna be
on a content where everyone sucks
yeah i mean the people that suck less by
coming forward and saying yeah i did
that bad [ __ ] and i feel really bad i'm
not gonna do it again
it's like those are going to be
marginally better than the people that
are like
they either don't think they did
anything wrong or they're like well i'm
just going to avoid
any repercussions for what i did i mean
obviously that's worse
and a lot of people who come from very
stable countries
western countries you know they they see
law as morality
you know which that's not what it is law
comes from a legal framework
you have to be able to prove things you
have to
there's things called jurisdiction
there's all these little [ __ ] details
that has to happen in order to get a
damn conviction
if not then it's not law you know
it's just morality immorality is not law
he did all this in a time of lawlessness
where there was no law
there was no functioning liberian state
the president of liberia was tortured to
death on live
television yeah imagine that
imagine you lived in a country where
that was happening
then you're going to convict some dude
and people complain about living people
living right
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
there was no legal framework in which to
get
any kind of conviction it was mad max
well
like i said they had the tribunal which
like i said if you watch the documentary
you can see
it but they didn't have any power to do
anything all they could do was make a
list and be like well we suggest
that these people give be given amnesty
we suggest that these people be trying
for war crimes
but no one did anything about it it was
just like a list that they made
you know what i mean so it's kind of
like
you know it was good that they did that
that it was acknowledged that everybody
in the country
saw it but it you know no action really
came
out of it right and you're going to get
a situation where
well we're going to try this dude well
under what law
you know well under the law that we have
now does the does the law that you have
now retroactive does it have
jurisdiction over the time
in which before it existed you know
donald trump yeah
it'd be like because because the legal
system wasn't isn't in existence at that
time it's
there's a bunch of little stip look
law is very technical and i'm too drunk
to explain it
you can do things in the high seas that
are [ __ ]
totally immoral all right and would be
highly illegal here in the united states
but because you're in international
waters you're not in an american
jurisdiction somebody else has to handle
that well that's exactly why some people
go out and
go on the high seas go do that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] because they know that no one's
gonna
right they're like what it's a
technicality right you can't you could
take a [ __ ] to mars
and cut his head off and not break any
laws that's not under anybody's
jurisdiction
yeah martians don't have any yeah
there's no law on mars
okay so when they [ __ ] bring you back
here to the united states and they say
we're gonna [ __ ] try you for murder
for cutting that motherfucker's head off
your [ __ ]
lawyer goes i object you can't he's not
within your jurisdiction so the grand
jury can never get the indictment
yeah you know they say well you wonder
who's and
that's the thing it's like that's what's
so kind of frustrating it's like there's
nothing we can do about it because
humans are humans we're imperfect
okay why don't you give me that why
don't you give me another drink while
you're out there
making another drink while you're out
there i mean like not while you're in
the bathroom but you know
but that's like this is one thing that
like frustrates me a lot about
law in general is that it has to be
because humans are imperfect
you have to you know when everyone's
different so they have to
construct it in a way that it's kind of
like best for everybody
but best for nobody at the same time
because it's like
it has to be you know ideally it has to
be like impartial it has to be
you know it's it's not in practice but
in
you know theory it's supposed to be you
know so
i don't know it really like bothers me
and i think and i feel like reading
about this case really like brought up a
bunch of
moral conundrums that that i do think
about a lot but i guess i hadn't really
like
uh you know it hadn't all like coalesced
until i was like
reading about this and like watching the
documentary last night and thinking
about how he would feel because
i'm kind of like one of those like even
in the united states
particularly and like i said i write a
lot about true crime i write about
serial killers and [ __ ] like that
so in general
i'm generally opposed to the death
penalty just because i think it's not
um fairly applied um
you know do i think that some people
just deserve to be like put down like a
rabbit dog yes indeed i do there are
some people but i think that's very rare
um do i think that people can change
within reason
some people that are serial killers or
psychopaths i don't think they're ever
going to change and i don't think that
um that there's probably any helping
them or that there's any way of like
putting them back
into society and being able to trust
them ever again so i do think if you
don't necessarily have to kill them but
i do think that you should keep them
away from other people as much as
possible
but the this kind of thing
where the where it was like situational
and i don't know this just like really
bothered me a lot and and it kind of
bothered me that
i kind of came to the conclusion putting
myself in the shoes of this one woman
that he was talking to whose
husband she that he had killed and i was
kind of thinking
you know even if he came to me the way
he came to this woman and he was like
you know contrite and he was seemed
genuinely sorry for what he had done
it's like i still felt like
i would want to see him
punished in some way for that and i know
that that i don't know it just bothered
me because i felt like it made me a bad
person like or a worse person than some
of the people in the documentary because
they seem to be able to forgive him
and i don't think i would be able to um
but you know that's everybody's
different i guess
and i don't know it just brought up a
lot of
uncomfortable [ __ ] for me because like i
said i always thought i was a good
person maybe i'm not as good a person as
i thought i was because
i was just kind of like [ __ ] that guy
seriously and tom's like no
it's like he's really sorry and i'm like
i don't buy it i'm just not buying it
and i was like really [ __ ] cynical
about it
and he was telling me that i was being
too spock-like i was being too cynical
and stuff and i'm just like i don't know
man it's like
thank you i'm just i'm just kind of like
i don't know i don't
i've just gotten to a point where i'm a
nice person but
i i have a hard time trusting other
people and
so that was kind of where i was coming
from with that i don't know
um i gotta i'm gonna i'm gonna go to the
bathroom so
you can like entertain the peeps for
a couple of minutes
so yeah he deserves a pass in the
quarters out of that okay
well i think it was a situational
i think it was i think it was a certain
situation you know what i mean that was
happening in liberia
um yeah he did a bunch of bad [ __ ] but
they were all doing bad [ __ ]
and uh yeah african culture had a lot to
do with it
the weird [ __ ] that the [ __ ] that he was
doing
was african it was very african it had
historical and cultural precedent to it
um even though other africans didn't
like it
like i said would be kind of like the
same difference between christianity and
satanism it was
satanic it was the african version of
satanism
juju magic
but it had been going on for a long time
you know
i think the main obstacle is [ __ ]
jurisdiction what court had jurisdiction
over liberia at that time
that's that's the issue
the only hope would have been something
like some kind of weird international
war crimes tribunal
but those tend not to have any teeth
because international war crimes
tribunals would
you know if they had any teeth could be
used against the united states and of
course the united states is not going to
[ __ ] fund any [ __ ] like that
well no we just want other people to get
in trouble for [ __ ] we don't want to get
in trouble
even if we even if we do the same [ __ ]
right well when we do it we have an
excuse but when you guys do it it's
[ __ ] right
so don't go one second think fairness
has anything to do with [ __ ] anything
all right fairness is not a factor all
right mostly has to do with political
power and money
you know if you got enough money you're
going to [ __ ] make it fair
you know what i'm talking about well
yeah if you have money you can get away
yeah if you have money you could have
no matter where you are you could have a
[ __ ] sex island
if you with underage girls on it you got
money
yeah yeah well yeah that's what i mean
it was people with money are going to
get away with anything um and that has
been true
throughout human history yeah uh sadly
he who owns the gold makes the rules
that's exactly [ __ ] what that goes
back to [ __ ] roman time that's what i
mean that's like
and it will probably always be true
sadly um
that's the thing and that's another
thing too i can't remember what it's
called but
that is a very human thing to think that
like okay when you do something [ __ ]
up
yeah you're like oh well i did this
[ __ ] up thing because
i was tired or i was drunk or i had some
other excuse
but if somebody else does the exact same
thing as you well they did that because
they're a bad person
that's you know what i mean what is that
called the attribution fallacy or
something like that
where it's like you think you did
something bad because of the
circumstances but the other person that
did the exact same thing as you
they did something bad because they're a
bad person
you know what i'm saying so that's like
a very human thing to do
yeah but yeah and you know don't for one
second think that
i'm [ __ ] casting dispersions on one
american political party versus the
other if you had
actual [ __ ] international war crimes
crimes tribunals that had gone over
they'd gone after obama too for [ __ ]
using drones on people
you know what i mean you can use
anything on anybody well everybody
everybody does i think every president
ever would be in trouble they'd be all
in trouble
every leader every [ __ ] because
everybody's done
they're all doing that bad they're all
doing it
i feel like i feel like even to get in
power in the first place
you got to be bad you have to be a bad
person
which that it's kind of shitty that yeah
this is why like i said i'm
i'm not going to be too sad if an
asteroid hits the earth because it's
just kind of like
well it's human nature it's it's human
nature
it's not my human nature well but
apparently good people just kind of sit
at home and
go with the flow all right they try to
be fair but if you're the kind of person
that wants to accrue
and amass a bunch of power see that's
immediately i don't trust you
yeah because you're gonna have to do
some [ __ ] that's the thing if you want
to be in power you
shouldn't be in power because already
you're a terrible it's
it's like nature's going to select who's
going to end up in power
and the ones that end up in power or
[ __ ] that are
watching that you don't want in power
yeah that's what
that's what i mean that's the whole
[ __ ] that's the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] of
your
nature people that are in charge are the
people that you never
want to be in charge here's the thing
and i want you know what i mean i'm
gonna get kirk versus her spock all
right
[Laughter]
listen he's always [ __ ] on my
spockness let's say you put a good
person in power
of the united states they'd be
cannibalized by all the evil
[ __ ] in the other countries
there ain't no fish up there it's all
sharks
that's right that's what's such about it
well and the thing about it too and
somebody pointed out there and this is
actually true
it's that i feel like people too have a
skewed sense
of how shitty most not people in power
because
most people in power are shitty but i
mean just regular people
most people are okay it's just you don't
hear about you only hear about the
shitty people because that's what gets
attention so i feel like there's a
little bit of
a you know it's it's kind of a thing
where
because you know crimes get
press shitty things get press
people doing just good [ __ ] doesn't get
any attention because no one cares about
that
so i do feel like there's kind of a
skewed perception too that like people
think that
[ __ ] is worse than it is just because
you hear about it more
you don't hear about a hundred people
over here doing something
good but not all that noteworthy um and
then you hear about this one
[ __ ] over here that's like oh
cut someone's head off or like fed
someone or a crocodile or some [ __ ] like
that because that's
gonna make news but the reason that it
makes news is because it's
unusual news is a business
it's like a [ __ ] problem they want
people to read it they want people to
click on it
they want the ad right it's all quickly
it's all clickbait so you have to think
too
and i i read a book about this not too
long ago where
they were saying that you know most
people are okay or
inoffensive or not doing anything
terrible it's just that
you hear about people doing horrible
things because it's rare
but because you hear about that more
than people doing good things because
nobody wants to report on that because
it's boring
then you get a skewed sense of like how
terrible people are because you're only
hearing about terrible people
not only that but you're also hearing
news through a certain framing and
framing techniques that they use
american news actually just news in
general
in the all in in the entire west if you
go through the history of the news
going back to the 1800s it's yellow
journalism and it's always been yellow
journalism well yeah like i said it's
it's [ __ ] fake people talk about [ __ ]
now but it's like it's always been that
way
it's always been that way it's always
been that way they're always just trying
to
like back in the day they were always
trying to sell newspapers particularly
and actually
if people [ __ ] about it now it was way
worse back in the early days
because there were in sometimes in some
cities but you know they didn't have the
internet obviously it was like the
[ __ ]
19th century they had several some big
cities would have like several competing
newspapers
so it's like they would be like well we
have to have the most salacious story
yeah to sell more copies than the
competitor yeah
so they would like just straight make up
[ __ ] and they weren't like embarrassed
about it either
the difference is is that in the 20th
century masters of propaganda
appeared writing [ __ ] books on how to
frame
and how to write news stories to make
them more effectively deceptive
old yellow journalism it was [ __ ]
obvious that that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
useful well yeah now they're what's next
now it's very scientific
sneakers um news is about is a product
to get you interested and to continue to
buy but not only that but it's to
pump certain narratives it's very much
like the advertising agency it is an
advertising agency
you can buy whatever news you want if
you have enough money you can pay a news
the the news industry to print whatever
story you want they call it a narrative
nowadays
well it seems like they take all those
stories apart and realize
and you're saying this isn't really news
it's opinion
they can [ __ ] mask opinion and well
yeah
it's it's dangerous now well like i said
this is where and i know you make fun of
me for my spockness but
this is where not only not only my
spockness but also the fact that i'm a
writer
and i'm a vocabulary nerd this like
helps a lot because when you see a
headline you can see a [ __ ] written i
immediately see like oh why did they use
that word instead of that word it's like
that's very loaded it's like you know
what i mean so
it's that just comes naturally to me
because i'm a writer because
i'm into like vocabulary so so it i feel
like i don't want to say like oh i don't
fall for it and [ __ ]
but in a lot of ways i see it for what
it is
the good thing about it is i think the
average people are starting to realize
that most of these
people are a lot more well the reason
that it had to get easier effective
was that people are a lot more cynical
nowadays people are a lot smarter than
they used to be
yeah um you know it as much as people
like say everyone so dumb notice no
millennials blah blah blah but it's like
actually people are a lot more media
savvy yeah
nowadays than they used to be um people
are very well aware of like all these
[ __ ] tricks that they use so it's
like people don't fall for it
as easily this is why like you see [ __ ]
where all of the dumbest [ __ ] who is
falling for that
nobody old people old people they're not
useful they're not they're not used to
it
they're used to believing everything
they're used to having opinions spoon
fed to them
13 o'clock is a neutral show all right
i lean right jenny leans left all right
i don't lean left i go
into that [ __ ] you're not a communist
though
no but you know you're not a marxist
communist it's
but you know i have a lot of libertarian
and liberal
values too okay i have libertarian views
depending on what i'm a civil liberties
libertarian in the sense that you know
[ __ ] that you're doing with your own
body
drug use yeah i don't yet legalize that
[ __ ] i believe the same prostitution
legalize that [ __ ] as long as it's uh
consensual i'm on the right
i don't believe felonies should be kept
track of
they didn't used to have that [ __ ] see i
agree with you on that
like after they let you if they let you
out you did your time you're [ __ ]
free
right you should get full citizenship
back including gun rights
because i do not believe in that well
because like they got rid of multibill
that was joe biden that did that [ __ ]
multi-bill was a [ __ ]
crime against humanity to give a dude a
life sentence because he had three
small felonies that's [ __ ] ridiculous
that was clinton wasn't it
uh biden was involved in that clinton
and biden were involved in that
it was because they they i mean they
were invested they were invested in the
prison system
they've prison systems should never be a
prophet making [ __ ]
well-known business that's
and when i say i'm on the right i'm not
on the 1980s
stereotypical [ __ ] evangelistic
that's not the right i'm talking about
uh i'm on the newer version of the right
which back in the day would have been an
old school democrat
you know what i mean i'd have been like
a 1960s democrat
yeah i mean like i said it i'm not in
any of that [ __ ]
as much as like we don't agree on like a
lot of politics
like um some of the [ __ ] because i have
like pretty libertarian views about like
prostitution drugs
yeah i don't see probably [ __ ] that you
were doing i do not believe
prostitution should be corporatized
that's dangerous i mean there should not
be corporate chains of brothels
people that is [ __ ] that's none of
anyone else's business yeah
like drug use or something like that um
that should not be correct constitution
should only be a private business
yeah i mean i don't believe it should be
illegal because i think that makes it
more dangerous
could you imagine a chain of brothels
like mcdonald's how dangerous that could
be to society
yeah but like i said i do see the i do
see the benefit in making it
legal in the sense for individuals
yeah well that's a girl's business
well it's just kind of like well it's
like anything else that has to do with
anyone's personal
like abortion or anything like that it's
like that is something that
is you know you and
that should be your decision i should be
able to decide if i
have an abortion i should be able to
decide if i want to marry someone of the
same sex
i should be able to decide that i don't
think it's the government's business i
don't think that that's anyone else's
business
it doesn't affect them it doesn't harm
them it's like that it's none of your
business it's not a victimless it's a
victimless thing
right you're not hurting anyone you're
not hurting anybody but what
jay and i can both both agree on and my
advice is do not consume
corporate news all right they lie
or at least what i do is i kind of like
read a lot of different
sources i trust on the same story
and see how different people are i trust
youtubers and vloggers and people that
are on the ground
over [ __ ] over a corporate news
agency they don't even have reporters on
the ground half the damn time
i just don't trust them and they're
being paid to sell certain narratives
that's my advice all right that i don't
i don't know what advice jenny might
give you something well and this well
the thing too my advice is
don't what you have to watch with that
too though is that you don't want to
fall
into the trap of getting into anecdotal
evidence
i mean you see two random ass
people on youtube selling one particular
narrative those are just two guys
and it's like you don't know like they
could be selling a narrative too
they're all selling narratives that's
what i mean everyone's selling a
narrative
so you really have to get like you have
to step back from [ __ ]
and get like a really show me somebody's
damn
[ __ ] cell phone [ __ ] video
something happened and that's what
that's the news for me
although in some ways too and as long as
i know the packs
even that well even that could be faked
because
a lot of [ __ ] too and what ends up
happening
is that sometimes people will film
something
and it will get even if they film it on
their cell phone and that's real
but it'll get picked up by someone else
and then misattributed
to yeah you can mislabel it and say it
you can mislabel it and say it's
something else
so it's like you can't just let the
buyer be aware yeah you can't trust
anything
you can't trust anything it's when you
know what the deal is which like i said
that's shitty
but you really have to like put work in
to
i would look into like you know who
benefits from this like
who filmed this like where did it come
from is this really like
attributed to the correct source yeah
but that if that that's also corporate
media
they'll [ __ ] twist it too but like i
said everyone will
so it's universal it kind of sucks
nowadays because you gotta [ __ ] be
smart you can't yeah you can't just like
take
don't be don't like one person's word
for [ __ ] you have to really put
i mean if you really care about an issue
because when you do that
right you just let them spoon feed you
that [ __ ]
then you fall in the same category as
our [ __ ] parents generations
they'd sit back and walter cronkite
could tell them [ __ ] anything
they'd just spoon feed them [ __ ]
anything and they had to have news in an
official
[ __ ] block of information to tell
them what to [ __ ]
think and if you go back in time and go
look at that [ __ ] that they were telling
them
it was a lie a lot of times not all
times but it was a distortion of reality
here's an example i'm getting way off
[ __ ] topic well that's okay all right
vietnam vietnam war all right
they sold the vietnam wars as if it was
a war against communism
to stop the spread of communism but if
you really looked at the details ho chi
minh
tried to make a deal with the united
states first and we turned him down
yeah i know it wasn't really against
communism ho chi minh just
took whatever support he could get
anywhere because
the ruling class of [ __ ] vietnam
south vietnam was really [ __ ] abusing
rice peasants over [ __ ]
[ __ ] what it was a bunch of [ __ ]
landlords renting out [ __ ]
land to grow rice on that was the
dispute it had nothing to do with
communism or capitalism nothing
it just had a veil of communism over it
because i feel like people are imposing
a larger narrative on something that
maybe didn't really happen only
military support ho chi minh could get
was through communist china but the
[ __ ] vietnamese hated the chinese
as soon as america was out they turned
on the chinese
you know what i mean and it was not as
communist as people think
it was it was you know what i mean had
we [ __ ] formed the alliance with ho
chi minh the communism thing would have
never come into [ __ ] play
it was land disputes between the
vietnamese
and we should never get involved in
somebody else's civil war i mean
all the [ __ ] that [ __ ] me and my boys
all went through because the united
states
and globalism and us trying to be the
[ __ ] world's policeman getting
involved in other people's civil wars
that did not [ __ ] benefit the united
states in fact it drained our
i mean that didn't involve us it never
none of this [ __ ] involved us
it would involve rich people who are
globalists
who have their fingers in everything and
live in all these different countries
trying to siphon money from the american
taxpayers into other markets that they
got their fingers in
it's all [ __ ] it's all about money
it's money in the end
right and the thing about it is that i'm
getting mad i'm gonna talk about it you
get mad i'm getting mad
xanada says i'm a millennial aka
seriously
i i feel like millennial has become one
of those things like look
i'm gen x he's gen x but i do not want
to be one of those people that is like
oh all people younger than me
suck or whatever because i know that
that is not the case and at this point
millennials are like
in their [ __ ] 30s and 40s i don't
know why people are still referring to
people
like that are teenagers and 20s and
they're millennials because
that's not the case anymore i feel like
the
generational thing is very uh reductive
and i don't think it's very productive
like saying that oh millennials do this
although i will say that
boomers in general do kind of suck but
not all of them but in a large
percentage
depending on what what's happening it
depends on what and which one you're
talking about
it depends on who i'm talking about yeah
and like i said i'm very into
i don't like labels i don't like
you have good you have good boomers but
some of them have not made the leap
into the world that we live in now
they're still seeing things from the
older paradigms
and look i'm old too i get that like i'm
i'm not
up with all the like latest [ __ ] or
whatever but they end up making mistakes
and one of the mistakes is is [ __ ]
swallowing the [ __ ] same old party
line and [ __ ] believing things and
just taking things at face value and not
understanding [ __ ] manipulation like
you were talking about
what she said yeah it's like what you
should like i said it's
in a way it's a lot harder for people
nowadays because there's so much
information coming at you and it's like
you don't really
it's a lot of work to sift through
everything
and decide what is
true or what is not it's you know what i
mean it's it's like a whole
job unto itself yeah like so i get that
and i get how it's very easy
for people to fall into a thing where
it's like well i like this one
particular channel i'm just gonna
believe whatever they say but you can't
[ __ ] do that you just can't nowadays
it's just like there's so much
information everywhere and i do feel
like
i mean i'm old i get tired yeah
it's like having to like keep track of
all of this [ __ ] i try to keep track of
[ __ ] too is
on top of all the other [ __ ] that i'm
doing you know the
whatever [ __ ] two or three jobs that
i have is that saying that he's sorry he
derailed the show
no no no it's like well at this point
we're like at three hours we were kind
of yeah we're almost done
we were kind of done yeah um yeah the
gen xers were not actually that
different for gen x gen x
we were very because we we saw
things getting [ __ ] up we knew that
what they were telling us wasn't going
to happen well our parents were boomers
so yeah and we kind of like i love my
parents
i do but i get yeah we were the first
generation
to be like they're look at our parents
and be like yeah that's not
what's happening couldn't give you guys
are kind of out of it well they couldn't
give you advice
on things because the world it was
changing their world was changing and
was going
away and they didn't really know they
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
and
and like you know the american life and
just [ __ ] the world was changing
so gen x was very skeptical
well [ __ ] skeptical we all are yes
um the difference is like
millennials they believe in things even
if they're not true
uh same thing with uh but
i can understand why they believe in
some of this [ __ ] it hasn't been
proven to be false yet they're
idealistic and
the young people are idealistic they
just but that's good though
they should be yeah i mean somebody
needs to be we can't all be cynical old
[ __ ] like we are that would like the
[ __ ] human race would die out yeah
there's just certain truths nobody wants
to be like shitty old people
they're just certain truths that are
universal okay
and
they're out there trying to change
things and they think that the change
will be legitimate
but it won't it won't be um
like for instance some of them are out
there trying to fight for a communist
revolution because they think that
they'll have a good standing inside of a
new communist society
they won't be they won't get anything
all you got to do is just look at the
other communist revolutions like in
the soviet union or the or cuba or
anything else
in the end who ended up running those
civilizations were right-wingers and
rich people
that's who ran those civilizations
that's who runs that's who always gonna
you're not gonna change anything they're
not gonna become they're gonna take
these antifa guys and make them cops
they make them cops they're gonna [ __ ]
up
they're gonna take those right-wing guys
who left the police and make them cops
again
just like in a clockwork exactly like
that exactly
they're just going to be common and now
you're going to have
right wing guys in a communist society
as the cops
they hate commies and they're going to
abuse the people
for being commies that's not going to be
a good situation that's what we're
saying
the kgb one of the most abusive groups
in the soviet union they
[ __ ] [ __ ] over so many russians and
[ __ ] you know why
because the kgb were right-wingers they
hated communism
and they hated commies they sent him all
the [ __ ] this [ __ ] was a true
believer
this sent him to gulag they didn't like
it they didn't like it
that's part of the reason why it fell
you can't change people's nature
you just can't so like i said this is
why i'm team asteroid
yeah team asteroids well no what it is
you gotta
you have to make a world that's live and
let live don't impose your values on
others
it has to be an even playing field
[ __ ] give everybody the right to
[ __ ]
live out their dreams don't [ __ ] take
other people's rights away it's easy
but there are a lot of control freaks
it's not though because a lot of control
freaks
well because everyone has a different
perspective everyone wants to control
some [ __ ]
yeah well i think that's kind of the
heart of the issue there
yeah stop trying to like impose your
[ __ ] on other people well
you need rules clearly you need uh
you know some kind of structure in place
but after a certain point
you have to leave people alone to do
what they're going to do
yeah you can't let them impose on other
people yep
clearly um you know to whatever
extent it's got to be a live and let
live type situation
yeah in in large measures yeah yeah
you got to have a system where left
wingers
cannot impose on right-wing people and
right-wing people can't impose on
left-wing people
that they have an even playing field and
they can [ __ ] live out their versions
of reality
in their own little [ __ ] spaces
that's what i mean let everybody do what
they want to do
don't [ __ ] well within reason yeah
yeah well no
you can't take rights away from other
people that's the difference right but
you know in a way too in some sense
if you live in a society you have to
give up some of your quote-unquote
rights in the
uh you know interest of larger
situations but it doesn't work it
depends on what it is though
it depends you got courts to decide all
that
depends on what courts decide that i
mean i don't know exactly exactly what
it is that you're talking about
it's it's probably almost time to end
the show anyway but it's just that
you can't impose on other people
that's really what it's about like i
said but
see the problem here is that everyone's
definition of impose
is going to be different because look at
someone who is
for example let's take an extreme
example let's say someone is a
psychopath
and they were like well i would like to
just be able to
do whatever i want and to like smack
other people at random
no they don't like that that's right
that's imposing that's
imposing but that's a crime that's
impossible and that should be a crime
that's what you got courts for but like
i said
imposing is going to be a different
situation because like i said let let's
look at the current pandemic let's look
at like the people that
are going out into places like not
wearing masks and like [ __ ] like that
where i feel like they're kind of like
well i have the disease and i don't care
if you get it or i'm just gonna like
touch people
in the [ __ ] grocery store and like
give them disease or whatever
so i do feel like there's kind of a
thing where you can impose on people
in the sense that look do the minimum
like wear a little piece of thing over
your face
it's like the minimum we can ask for and
don't give other people diseases i don't
think that's imposing on anyone's
rights or foreign where do you draw the
line right but see that's like a
slippery slope
you can go like you can go like well
we're not talking about coving we're
talking about all diseases
so that ways everybody has to wear a
mask forever
in fact you got to stay at home and live
in a [ __ ] blood that is a slippery
slope
yeah exactly that's a slippery slope
argument but the thing is okay
now we talked about we did a show about
pandemics before this all this [ __ ] went
down and we talked about the spanish flu
now spanish flu killed millions
of people yeah this one is now the
numbers aren't there
well yeah but the thing about it is that
even people that don't die from it
have a lot of like uh symptoms that
continue but can we prove that yes we
can
what are the what i like to see this
proof what are we talking about
because alex jones says it's frying your
nuts
it's sterilizing you can we like i don't
believe that
well good because alex jones is a crazy
person i don't know i think josh jones
is a [ __ ] genius he's maybe he's
making more money than me
but i'm saying yes because
i would like to see i would like to see
the evidence
i think it's based on i don't want to
get the [ __ ] and like
honestly i you know based
let me finish based on my research what
i found
infection on the thing is pretty high
but mortality is only
about four times what the normal flu is
which still isn't very much
that's not good though but it still
isn't very much and it's not
that women finish it's not
backing up the health care system in
other words
it is in florida in in florida and in
texas in arizona i believe several other
states
i don't see dead bodies at the end of
the [ __ ] road though
you're not talking about a true place
death is not
the worst thing that can happen today
you're not seeing a true plague
yes they said they said we are they said
what today
two and a half million no when when when
the world health organization and
faucino
they first said i think they said two
and a half million dead within the first
few months and that didn't happen
two and a half million it's not even the
thing about it though is that death
is not the worst thing what they are
finding
now that they didn't realize at the
beginning was that people that had it
and
recovered have had lasting
very unpleasant effects from this
[ __ ] flu because this is kind of
unprecedented it's related to other flu
that happened in the past
but uh has had some lingering effects
that are really not all that pro is it
pleasant
so i feel like look
i feel like here's the shitty thing i
feel like all these stupid people
that are walking around i don't want to
wear a mask and they're making it into
some kind of stupid political statement
it's like you were saying that a mild
inconvenience
on your part wearing a piece of fabric
over your face
is that is that is more important
than if you gave somebody else a disease
that could potentially kill them or give
them
lifetime symptoms
that are not pleasant so why like i
don't get the selfishness
but that's with any disease i just don't
get it that's with any disease though
that's not really a good that's not
really
look at the numbers that's with any
disease i mean you might accidentally
give somebody
aids or [ __ ] any other kind of
disease how can you accidentally give
somebody eight
yeah you're getting there you're deep in
this [ __ ] well that's not an accident
is well you didn't know that you had
aids
yeah but that's one person there's all
kinds of [ __ ]
diseases that can be the thing about
well aids
is only past and actually that's like
more curable nowadays but it's like aids
is only like sexually transmitted or
transmitted
through blood the flu is transplanted
like through the [ __ ] air
and by you touching [ __ ] so i feel like
a mild inconvenience on the part of
you know one person over here could
potentially save many lives or
potentially
save many illnesses over on this side so
it's like why wouldn't you do that
it just seems like you're being
deliberately
dickish not to do that just because
you're trying to make some kind of
statement about
your freedom or whatever and it's like i
don't really get that
it makes me very angry and it's like i
don't understand that mentality because
you are
essentially putting your own wants like
i don't want to wear a piece of fabric
on my face for half an hour but i don't
care if i get 100 people
sick that's really i don't think i don't
think that's
really you're being a [ __ ] taint
you're being a taint at that stage and i
don't really have any patience for you
i'm not really and i hope that you die
of coping
i mean seriously and people that do that
just die of coping i don't
really buy it i don't think it's that
fact well that's your prerogative
as your dad says about the turkiness but
i don't think so i'm just if it
it's nothing it's nothing to you it's
nothing to you
to wear a piece of evidence how long
something how long is it going to last
for
does it matter it doesn't matter to me
it doesn't matter it can it can go on
for the next hundred years
and go out the next 20 years 30 years
honestly i'm not bothered
i don't want to give other people
diseases what happens what happens if it
goes on for another 10 years but it
collapses civilization
i'll worry about that [ __ ] when it
happens what if you die during the
collapse
well then i'll die but wouldn't it just
be easier to just let the [ __ ] run
free and then [ __ ] get hurt immunity
and let the weak die off just like in a
darwinistic society to where that's the
way diseases normally work
yeah but let that [ __ ] spread and let
everybody catch it
i don't know if that's really the best
situation i mean that's what happened
with the black
death and all the other [ __ ] plagues
yeah and we still talk about this [ __ ]
nowadays like that was a horrible that's
the world though
you know i mean the world is [ __ ]
horrible yeah but the thing about it is
nature isn't isn't moral like that
here's the thing though
is that see this is the naturalistic
fallacy
just because something is like something
oh well that's just the way she did so
we should just let [ __ ] happen like that
it's like i don't really i don't buy
into that [ __ ] i don't
under the given [ __ ] data that
they're giving us
in terms of transmission rates you can't
stop the spread of it
everyone will eventually get it anyway
yeah but
i don't know yeah but if okay
if you can just like mildly
inconvenience yourself to minimize that
wouldn't you do that i mean i would no
i don't really care yeah obviously you
don't
because you're an associate no i can
face death you know what i mean
i can face death in the world okay well
i'll just
i'll get covered and die yeah i'm sure
you ain't gonna die you won't give a
[ __ ] about that
you ain't gonna die when you look at the
data you don't know that there's people
mostly in their eighties and they're
nice
no it's not well anybody not anymore
anybody can die though anybody can die
of any of these diseases some people
so you don't care about that it just
happens it's like a roll of the dice
you know what i mean this is luck luck
and [ __ ] probability and
i don't worry about it i've always been
you've heard it here first
i've always i'll die of cobit and he
will not care i'll stop it i've always
been in a situation where you could
possibly die it's just
that's just normal you could possibly
die
well i think i don't die i'm just saying
that
i'm not into this whole safety trip you
know i mean like yeah anyone could
possibly die
at any time i could walk outside
tomorrow and get hit by a bus
okay right that's not what we're talking
about though
that's just like a statistical
probability okay it's probably not going
to happen but it could i could go
outside and get
right in with captain kirk okay spock
you're dealing with captain kirk it's
just
it's just probability chance it's the
role that dies this is why
okay this is why i drink it it could
happen this is why i drink listen to it
because you can't
like reason you can't reason with a
[ __ ] like me
because he doesn't have any logical no
it's logic it's a different kind of lie
i'm stepping back in and i'm looking at
it in the big picture that's not i'm
looking at it that's not what it is okay
it's not what it is
it's it's time to end the show anyway
it's not what it is
it is you just tell yourself that it's
logic but it is logic i've got this [ __ ]
all [ __ ] worked out in the big
picture i'm sure you do
i'm sure if i die oh i'm gonna die
you're gonna die we're all gonna die
eventually i'm gonna see you in the
afterlife
no you're not yeah because there's no
such thing that's just what you're
thinking i'm gonna be in the afterlife
with general butt naked
recycling into the next action they're
by yourself because that's the next
action movie and [ __ ]
me and dolph lundgren and [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
and fun see here's what people
here's what people don't understand
about steven seagal
[Music]
you know tom i thought i told you why
why would you want to hang out with
stephen
no it's just it's just part of that he's
just gonna like hang around and he won't
be able to get rid of him
god damn it stephen's it's the afterlife
it's supposed to be like heavenly and
[ __ ] and here you are just like lurking
steven's goal is like lurking and he's
just like with his big gut and he's like
[ __ ] you know tom i heard what you
said about my movies
he's never gonna leave you alone in the
afterlife he's just always gonna be
there
[Laughter]
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i didn't
use a stand-in to [ __ ] walk down the
stairs that was me
i'm not that i'm not as fast as you
think i am i went on a diet
so his fatness is an illusion this is
all an illusion it's part of my ninja
skills
look i gotta go oh i gotcha okay i i buy
that
steven seagal is like making himself
look fatter like as a ninja yeah it's
ninja it's
camouflage yeah kind of okay i buy it
i'm just well here's the thing that a
lot of people don't understand about
uh atheists like myself is that
they think that we think that this life
nowadays like
like that you're living right now
doesn't matter but
atheists actually think this life
matters more than anything
because you don't get anything that's
right that's why you don't get
you don't get anything after you better
do all the [ __ ] you want to do nowadays
you better tell the people you love them
you better sell them nowadays
because it's not you don't get anything
else that's why
this is it that's why atheists are the
way they are i'm a mythicist
this is it okay my mythicist i you know
i uh i know there's a afterlife i've
seen it
[ __ ] make good make good with what
you got because you don't
there's all kinds of [ __ ] that she says
doesn't exist that i showed it to her
i showed it to her and in the atheist
world it wouldn't be a reality but
[ __ ]
yeah but the poltergeist [ __ ] that was
just you though yeah but there's also a
spirit realm
but okay
they call it a spirit realm it is not a
spirit realm in the way that you're
thinking
it has to do with [ __ ] quantum
physics and quantum mechanics it's a
[ __ ] slightly higher dimension
and it it's not only a dimension of
sight in the sound of the mind
i'm [ __ ] happy yeah no [ __ ] but
no there's there are other dimensions to
[ __ ]
and there it and i can't explain it
right now
i'm too too kind of drunk but uh
kind of no you you you live on in a
certain way
there's a quantum soul the quantum soul
theory i [ __ ]
i know it's a reality but uh
now it's not it's not a kind of
situation where general button
is talking about recycling into the next
action movie that's not it's not exactly
like that you know what i mean but
you your point of view does it
turns up again into the next one but
your point of view
is transferred you know what i mean
into another into another realm and you
can you can reincarnate
but you don't have to either you're
outside space time
that's good i don't i don't really i'm
kind of sick of this [ __ ]
it seems to be thank you nico thank you
very much buy more booze
like we need anymore
i but seriously i'm just like do you
know
listen to how depressing this [ __ ] is so
sometimes like i'm
uh almost 48 years old so sometimes i
think to myself like if i don't go
like dive covet or get hit by a bus or
whatever it's like
um from a realistic standpoint i could
probably live for another
30 maybe 40 years depending i'm fairly
healthy you know
and when i think about that i'm just
like
ugh
and it's like kind of like i mean i'm
looking forward to it because i have a
lot of [ __ ] that i want to get done i
have a lot of books i want to write i
have a lot of [ __ ] i want to read i have
a lot of [ __ ] i want to do
but then a lot of ways i kind of feel
like god that's oh
that's such a long time thanks guys it
seems like a long time that's for
general button
thank you matt but you know what i mean
is do i think there's an afterlife no
no i think she's wrong but i'm okay you
know that's fine
i'm okay with that though and i'm okay
with it because
i feel like it makes this life more um
important i feel like if you want to do
something you have to do it
now you have to like if you want to
write that novel if you want to [ __ ]
go to that
on that [ __ ] yeah no but to do it now
because you can't you won't do it
do it now like you said you can't have
any fear you got to go out and [ __ ]
embrace [ __ ] well that's
monsters don't worry about these
diseases and [ __ ] i mean yeah you don't
get yourself sick
well don't get other people sick either
you have to think about other people too
i don't exist other than that's not
that's not is
that's not as big of a deal as people
think it is i mean
well for me it is because i'm a person
and i care
about the people that the people that
you would get sick would have gotten
sick
anyway probably through somebody else uh
the people the people that would be
susceptible to the death
everybody's going to catch it if the
transmission rate is what they said it
is
eventually everyone would catch it but
this isn't the only disease that's out
there there's a lot of other ones
okay a lot of other little viruses and
here's another thing
that [ __ ] was bioengineered that was a
bio weapon not a
particularly good one but there's
probably a better one
that they're going to release this one
was just a warm up
they're going to hit us with another one
you watch
because we're at war just that people
don't realize it okay
we're at war with china yeah
we are it just hasn't been announced
this is a new kind of it
we're at war with china it'll come to
light in the next couple months
honestly there's enough diseases in the
world that
uh i don't even think we have to
engineer them there's another happening
by accident
often enough that some people don't that
[ __ ] is a
something that came out of a bat that
they [ __ ] with yeah okay
technologies are good man they can make
it they can make all kinds of weird [ __ ]
this is just i'm not endorsing this all
right uh just his
opinion reality has a strange way of
proving
thomas [ __ ] ross true well and
if it doesn't he'll
if it doesn't he'll just forget that he
said it let's see this
listen to this [ __ ] okay that's how
that's
look that's how psychics work that's how
noster thomas works that's how
nostradamus worked
you just no no no no there's a big
difference between nose and thomas and
nosfer thomas
big difference i don't know if there is
that poetic [ __ ] just said
everything and i don't just say some
vague [ __ ]
no if it comes true then you
say yeah i said this if it doesn't come
true you just like no
then you forget that you said it i know
what i'm seeing i have the training in
the background
and the education all right tradecraft
is going on
timing okay not right [ __ ] there's a
bunch of [ __ ] that happened
at specific times specific times and the
players involved
this is this is planned this is a war i
know what they're doing
this is [ __ ] james bond [ __ ] this is
spectre
it's coming she doesn't believe me
because
i'm tell you something she's a good
person that's why she doesn't believe me
i'm evil so i understand how thank you
elsa
thank you very much i understand how
evil works all right
if i was an enemy of the [ __ ] united
states i'd be doing exactly what you see
right now
because you're terrible i'm [ __ ]
terrible but the thing is i'm not an
enemy of [ __ ]
americans and american people in western
civilization
it doesn't know what i'm saying let me
read what this message says i know what
i'm seeing
[Laughter]
people's perceptions can be warped
though thank you very much
ilsa is that elsa yeah okay your shirt's
coming by the way we mailed it yesterday
yeah mailed this it mailed that thing
out
yeah she says i agree a bit more with
jenny thank you
that's estrogen that's estrogen doing
that [ __ ] that's how you guys work
i understand it i understand it so we're
we're women so we don't
understand how the world actually works
i'm not saying that
i didn't say that that's what you
implied though no they're they're
they implied that there's a female
dimension there's a male dimension too
okay yeah like i said that's all it is
girls don't understand how reality works
i'm not saying that i'm just saying that
there's a different aspect of reality
than women
you want to hear something funny okay
this is kind of going off on a thing
i don't know if like okay other
women the show's over tell me yeah
tell me if this makes you mad so you got
time for this
no i'm just i'm going there she's going
to [ __ ] attack me why
i'm not attacking you okay i'm just
saying that okay so in my
home office here sometimes the air
conditioning is very cold
right it's very cold in here so
sometimes i'll go back in the bedroom
and i'll get a sweater so i'll put a
sweater on
even in the summertime it's very cold in
here feet eliminated
so then yeah so tom will come into my
office
and he'll say what the [ __ ] are you
wearing a sweater for
and i say because i'm cold obviously
and then he'll always say quote unquote
it's not cold in here it isn't
and i'm like oh okay
it is a cold it looks cold in here
that's why i put a sweater on
be like seventy-five because it's cold
here it's like man 75
women are non-circulatory [ __ ]
they don't have any circulation see
there's always cold to them
it's not cold plus you see there's
something about
men with the testosterone we got the
[ __ ] dog
age the dog years you know that's why
y'all died
in dog years [ __ ] and our metabolism
is running
a little bit harder so we're warmer
yeah right but the fact that you think
that your perception
is his reaction is disturbing because
there's a [ __ ] man that made up
what a fahrenheit is this
and it has to do with right temperature
of human blood all right
it has to do with the temperature of
human blood that was the baseline i mean
why would i but
it it was the temperature of a man's
blood it bothers me because
he thinks that the implication being
that i would just put a sweater on just
because why are you so cold
because i'm cold duh okay
look i just put i just put a sweater on
for no reason no because i'm [ __ ]
cold
it's late it's late it's late the show
is over and the kids are still
watching this man come on we only got 32
people watching us right now i don't
know why that's just
that bothers me so much because yeah
xander you should feel bad bro you
started all this [ __ ] man
you started all this yeah that's all
right we were done talking about it we
do this [ __ ] all the time
like i said the [ __ ] general butt
naked he's still around yeah
he's an evangelist yeah i'm i'm
conflicted
about the [ __ ] you see red harvest is
saying chicks are always cold they are
they're always [ __ ] i'm not always
cold actually feet are always cold
no that's that's not the case okay like
and actually sometimes in the
bedroom like sometimes i get really hot
like sometimes it's hot in there so it's
like it's not like
everything but in the office for some
reason like i don't know if it's because
i'm sitting under the [ __ ] vent or
whatever
but it's really cold in here so
sometimes i go and like get a [ __ ]
sweater
and like he gives me [ __ ] about it he'll
give a [ __ ]
every time you come in here and you give
me [ __ ] about it why are you wearing
she's drunk i'm saying
why are you wearing sweater and it's
like because i'm i only did that a
couple of times
it was funny though it was funny
i was like what are you cool it just
reminds me of like all those [ __ ]
episodes of the haunting where like the
woman is like [ __ ] look at it
and he's like i'm crazy
this is like it's so like dismissive and
it's just like it bothers me a lot
i'm like look i'm cold that's why i put
a sweater on
why would i put a sweater on if it
wasn't cold and then he says it's not
cold and i'm like well
what do you want me to do with that
information i feel cold
so jenny we've had too much to drink we
got to industry
we got industry hey i hope you guys
enjoyed this show holy crap we went all
those four hours yeah
we've got an industry shit's going on
too long even though we're still making
money but we got it in the stream
it also says my boyfriend's a dutch oven
it's like i'm not
i'm
that was you man that [ __ ] cat laid
down next to me one time
[ __ ] with her ass right near my face
i was asleep that cat [ __ ] farted she
does do that nearly drove me out of the
goddamn bed burn my nose hairs off
that's how bad that came i mean
that big and it was enough to [ __ ]
just drive me out of the damn
level well that's how come i know that
like when it's you and her because
she's bad she like only farts
every now and then yeah but she'll
usually fart when she's like sitting
right on your chest or something she'll
fart right in your face like haha
yeah and it's like yeah it'll like it's
like a chemical warfare
i mean so that's why like when you do it
you're like
kooky and i'm just like shut up that was
you yeah but you know what i mean so i
know like the difference
it's bad but it's not that bad but yes
somebody said uh yeah the [ __ ] her
boyfriend's gross she's [ __ ]
right due to gross with departing yeah
we understand it blaming it on the cat
yeah jesus christ all right well we
gotta end this stream jenny we've been
on it for four
[ __ ] hours i can't believe it and we
mostly talked about general button well
kinda
yeah more than we did what was that one
show that we did where i feel like we
hardly talked about the topic
more people are coming in
[Laughter]
go ahead and shut the screen down all
right you ready shut it down alright
alright so thank you everybody for
dropping by
we are obviously very messed up yeah
and it's so early it's only eight it's
only eight o'clock 8 41
it's 8 41 p.m i got to deal with this
rest of the night she's gonna be [ __ ]
with me the rest of the night
i'm trying to bet she's going to be
making fun of me
she's running she's making fun of me you
love it okay
come on
making fun of me for being cold for
being spock and for being smart
you know you know how you do oh you took
your hat off
look he got no he got a haircut today
yeah
i cut it i got them all cut well most of
them
shut the stream down jenny okay shut it
down
all right you guys have a good rest of
your weekend have a good rest of your
saturday night you guys have a good one
uh remember like share subscribe do all
that kind of [ __ ]
and uh we will probably actually we'll
probably do another live stream tomorrow
i think we're gonna review that okay
indonesian horror movie
oh yeah yeah it's actually very good
yeah that's on shutter
so we'll probably review that tomorrow
so we'll be back tomorrow
to talk to you guys so thanks for
dropping by we'll see you see you later
bye
that was a good show